welcome back uh we're sorry about that
we had some
we had a blackout never heard of that
one before but stranger things have
happened in 2020 let's jump right back
into the action
uh with the yes and peter uh thank you
for that tanya
indeed we had an unscheduled technical
blackout peter
if you could go back to the position
before white played the move
knight h4 i just wanted to say that
uh boris baskey had played jakob yukman
and jakob didn't play the move
h6 but went f5 and
allowed white to play knight g5 and
boris went on to win a very nice game
and that's why
the move h7h6 is so important
but it's also peter a move that black
really is reluctant
to play yeah exactly because uh
h6 is very nice of stopping knight g5 on
the other hand
exactly as we see in the game uh
dingling very nicely
puts his knight on h4 basically
anticipating this whole
plan from black with f5 he takes f5 kind
of typical in this position you don't
want to
give black the chance of playing f5 f4
because then
this bishop on g2 will feel uh quite
awkward there will be too many
weaknesses on the
on the king side so it's typical to
exchange on f5
gtx f5 now white has a very harmonious
king side
but it all comes down to strategical
nuances once
this pawn let's just imagine the pawn
being on h7 then black would have the
very nice strategical idea of going
knight g6 because the pawn from h7 could
capture
back after knight x g6 but with the pawn
on h6
this very nice move knight g6 is not
possible this is one of black's problem
in the position
so white puts extra pressure on the f5
pawn with queen c2 black goes knight f6
white goes b4 black plays the move
bishop d7 he feels like i should finally
develop all my pieces and white
went on to strike with c5 and while we
had this break we're discussing
this position with yaster and some all
the moves that happened in the game
happened also in our in our minds during
our
discussion because it all felt very very
logical and the asia put it what happens
peter after e5
e4 and we were about to to answer it
but we already we were trying to answer
it but
now already we have it on the board and
dinglin has played the move
c5 c6 so i'm cheating and
so yeah sir my move is c6
and f3 and please tell me how you want
to continue with black
very nice very well well put well again
i think that
during that whole uh blackout period boy
we were having such a wonderful
discussion and uh i teased tanya i said
that uh now her rating should be
going through the roof and she confessed
that
uh without over the board competit
uh competitions coming up her motivation
to study has gone down now
f2 f3 you know a long time ago you were
mentioning how this bishop on g2 was
buried
behind a pawn on e4 and behind a pawn
furthermore on d5 so this bishop on g2
really didn't have a life but as we know
peter the bishop on g2 is a loyal
protector of the king
so it was even though it it wasn't
playing an active role in the game
it's really a good king defender now the
move
f2 f3 is perfect you have to play such a
move because you have to strike
in the center and black was about to
play moves like bishop f7
and in a way just simply round up this
pawn on d5 so it's a very uh big
um i want to say timing you know who
gets there first right
so after the move f2 f3
it's all i i have this question of
you know time so let's go bishop f7
peter
because again i'm thinking that black's
idea is just
to round up the pawn on d5 and i guess
you have to take
on on uh e4 and i would take and
again i think you have to take on e4
and here i don't want to trade pizza so
much because
as a king's indian player of sorts
i i i don't really play a proper king's
indian i play
a hybrid king's indian uh i like the
king's indian
attacking positions i can get so i try
to keep pieces
knight f6 takes d5
yeah it's it's a very sharp position
however in the game magnus
captured immediately on d5 oh
okay you know willingly trade
trading pieces okay i mean he just uh
saw that okay this pawn on d5 is there
let me take it because it really
disturbs me
and before white gets f takes e4 in yeah
okay yes game continued knight takes d5
knight xd5
ftx e4 and now i believe the big
question is can black somehow use the
tempo on c3 or or what is happening
right so uh in a kind of a funny way the
knight on h4 was offsides right but the
knight on h4 was also kind of this
preventive restraining kind of knight
preventing
black from getting his pieces out now
suddenly you know there are weak squares
on the light squares f5 and g6
and maybe this knight suddenly has a
good role to play
so when you play a move like knight c3
peter uh
you know the first impressions i've
always
i i i i want to say uh uh
i i don't want to go along with your
agenda i mean
you're attacking my rook and it's sort
of like yeah i know you're going to take
the rook but
can i do something else then go along
with your
script because i'm a little bit afraid
if i go rook b3
you may play you know some kind of move
like rook a2
and maybe i get less and less happy
about what's happening so i start to
think can i use my knight on
h4 could i go knight takes f5
and sacrifice and exchange
peter yeah you can
but where does it lead i mean okay let's
let me take let me take your look as i
said yes
and i'll take the night sure yeah you
take the night and
uh yeah it's a good question i mean i
already revealed that my favorite world
champion was tigran petrossian so
any action sacrifice comes very natural
to me
very very logical very logical
yeah and i'm with you but i can also
somewhere
eventually sacrifice it back i don't
know exactly the pawn on c6 is hanging
so does the h6 pawn yeah it's very very
complicated and
right i would love to analyze this
position but magnus done to two minutes
had to
make up his mind quickly and he already
shows something else
basically indicating he does not want to
calculate or does not want to allow any
of
it and he first captured on e4
right and bishop takes e4 and only then
played the move knight c3 so he didn't
give white this
option of sacrificing the exchange and
by the way uh
two minutes in such a complex
position i i'm thinking that
uh ding feels like he's got a chance a
very very serious chance
in this game peter absolutely fully
agreed i mean uh
seven minutes versus two and it feels
like there should be something on the
other hand it's such a position if
uh blacklist survived the next few moves
then
if he managed to eliminate white's light
squared bishop then he will have
everything under control so it's all
about timing the question and
look at this dingoes bishop takes h6
boom
whoa
okay we have this expression you know
lightning out of a clear blue sky you
know like
whoa that was quite the strike peter
yeah absolutely i mean but such
such moves are exactly the most you want
to make when your opponent is done to
two minutes and it also feels very much
in the spirit you have to keep your
momentum going
you cannot give the initiative to your
opponent and
black has this problem that his knight
on cc
attacks the bishop on e4 and the knight
the rook on b1
but does he have the time to to take and
which one he can only take one piece
and also we should not forget that
bishop takes h6 hit the pawn and
white is ready to exchange black's
almost only defender the bishop on g7
so very very dangerous situation for
black
absolutely and the whole tactic is based
on the idea that if you take the bishop
bishop h6 queen takes c3 and thank you
very much i've won upon
and have eliminated this very very
disturbing night
so i i i guess uh
that that kind of leaves uh magnus in
the situation of taking the rook and
and and with with no
with no pawn shield in front of his king
uh
i don't know how to to say it it looks
promising for white so knight takes b1
peter bishop takes g7
king takes oh i'm even not sure about
bishop take g7 because we have some
intermediate checks
oh oh is that this might be just made by
force
and magnus played the move queen f6 with
44 seconds on the clock
basically making sure that he gets
another defender instead of the bishop
on g7 namely the
the black queen ah so knight takes b1
you wanted to play
in case of knight takes b1 you want to
play bishop d5 check
bishop f7 queen g6 beautiful but then
you still have the move queen f6 it
still goes on
okay so by far i mean it's
it's not clear at all but uh really
there are so many
alternatives i i basically also fully
agree as a player that intuitively with
little time on the clock you you might
just also believe your opponent that
okay bishop h6 knight takes b1 this
just doesn't feel right it cannot be
right okay i there are all these dangers
all these clouds run my king
uh let let me play queen f6 because okay
uh after all with this knight on
uh is maybe the the best i mean clearly
the best piece for
black and it gives counter chances so
if he can make sure that his king
remains intact
then he still has good chances for
counter play
okay so queen f6 uh defending the knight
on c3 stopping bishop d5 checks by
retaining the knight hitting the bishop
on h6
most obvious move dare i say it bishop
takes g7 peter
yeah bishop g7 but uh i mean okay if you
exchange
i even don't know to take with the king
or no okay probably i take with the
queen
right because otherwise you get knight
f5 check x option
right but you anyway have knight f5
somewhere okay i take with the queen
okay
so knight f5 sure looks like a very
attractive tempo and uh i'll do it
okay can i can i take one f5
yes f5 i mean let's not forget i also
have some
unpleasant checks maybe on d4
okay uh i am a pawn up right
yeah but the c6 pawn is hanging ah yes
of course it is that's right
but but england and i like the i like it
a lot he he played bishop a7 he keeps
the momentum going
and king h8 i mean this is in the spirit
i agree it certainly is
wow okay i mean a moment or a
giving the less on the next day
you're the student receiving a lesson
just a game ago i
it's hard to believe but a game ago
magnus carlson played a nearly flawless
game
this looks like ding is returning the
favor here this is amazing
bishop h7 king h8 rookie eight beater
and magnus down to 11 seconds
yeah it's it's terrible and useful
magnus yeah look look at xc8 knight g6
played takes h7 but where does it lead
yeah knight f8
check double check it takes the bishop
he's taking the walk he's walking the
plank
queen h7 check king g5 forced
uh where's the mate where's the mate
well it's it's right there no queen f4
checkmate
queen f4 made wow
it looks like a mate yeah it is a mate
but you know i just cannot
cannot understand one thing couldn't
black go with the king to
to g8 i guess he was afraid of queen
ah no no okay everything right because
after king takes f8
uh first you take on g7 we check yeah
this is the exactly
and then you follow with luka f1 because
it was so natural that
you play you play first look f1 but then
black could have taken on f1 himself
right yeah just the intermediate move
the exchange on g7 and then look f1 wins
the game because
you cannot uh cannot parry the threats
holy wow holy smokes i mean we have uh
we have a blackout on our communication
broadcast
and right then decides
one of the most brilliant games of the
tournament uh
gets to be played uh our apologies for
that but
boy we gotta catch up with the fact that
now the match is all tied peter
one to one what a comeback and what a
beautiful final position
yeah absolutely and you know it's this
is what i meant already in the previous
days as well that when you
lose people say you are not informed
when you win then suddenly you are
informed
it's such small little nuances decide
whether you get informed because ding
finally got his position and he
managed to show what a great player he
is
tanya are you amazed as we are
absolutely peter as they say form is
temporary
class is permanent and talking about the
commentators guess the moment we said
that
things are looking bad for ding and ken
ding come back he just strikes back
and in style i mean that was a crushing
victory
um the only moment that stood out for me
after which actually ding just handled
it
amazingly was this position where he
uh right before white went c6 if we can
have that up
and instead of e4
instead of e4 here the plan the correct
plan and the correct way for black to
handle this position is to go queen e8
and to keep this d7 bishop
on this diagonal making sure that the f5
pawn is defended
uh in all lines he has to go e4
eventually and
f3 will be played but in all lines if
the bishop stays on the c8 diagonal just
making sure that the f5 pawn
is protected black's doing fine but
after white got in c6 and black's bishop
went
to e8 it was just flawless play by ding
just building up on the attack
sacrificing the pawn on d5 not caring
about all of that
and uh magnus perhaps could have had
better resistance but
it was still a very difficult position
in all lines
and the finish getting checkmated on the
f5 square
definitely the confidence boost that
the confidence boost that uh ding lehren
needs
in this match we do have you know we're
watching we're watching
these matches between uh between legends
and between champions but i am
very very i'm delighted to announce that
we have another champion with us
uh we are being joined by somebody whose
story whose uh whose life story has
moved and inspired everybody
across the world and uh uh i think
it's just it's just truly
it's truly a story about how human love
and human support
can overcome all adversities and all
challenges
and have this amazing impact on
somebody's life
and then how chess can just be the
miracle that makes dreams come true
and let's welcome because i see he's on
our screen and we've got
tani adaboomi with us hi dani uh
how are you doing good hello yeah
annie it's amazing to see you have you
been following uh following the action
on the tour
yes i see that max one and then gloss
did you see that last game it was pretty
pretty crazy you know
yeah the king's indian
it went wrong and does it does it
also the computer hates the king's
indian cell why play it
but it's a human so it's more reasonable
danny i've heard you're quite the
attacking player so can i assume that
you like playing the king's indian with
the black pieces
um no no
probably play something else all right
fair enough now tell me before we talk
about other stuff
in this store who is who are you rooting
for
me naka well he's made it to the final
that must have made you happy
and uh what about in the magnus ding now
ding is kind of
ding is playing catch up how would you
how would you say are his chances
of um of being able to beat
magnus into the finals i think so what's
the score right now
so magnus is two sets uh two dings one
so and magnus needs to win one more set
to qualify for the finals it's the best
of five
so i think dink probably like
mostly when he draws the game that's
when he gets his luck and beats magnus
so i think he should if he has luck
maybe he can draw two games and then
get madness by the hook
tanya you mentioned that your favorite
player is uh
is hikaru what do you like about his
style
marv's attacking me
with the grown adult and i've also seen
that you guys play a lot of uh do a lot
of puzzle rush together how's that
experience doing you know puzzle rush
for them
yeah i've gotten better so i mean last
time
i i just needed to learn more but i've
gotten better so
now um
maybe i have the
a good confidence that i can beat him in
that in a 10
uh and 10 game match
wow so danny you're saying that in a 10
game match you
you think that right now you can take
him on yeah
i i love it i love it and what do you
think it is about
your style or your way of playing that
hikaru should watch out for
um like i know how to make
tactics on the board like it's like a
positional position
but then like i know how to like make it
make it more tactical more of my style
uh yeah i have the best chance of
beating him um because
i got a 54 and three minute
puzzle battle and
yeah most of that so i mean and
he has a 48 so it's a six point
difference
that's insane panic is my high score on
the on the puzzle rush has been 41
on a really good day that makes me
question my life choices okay
now it's been sorry gone
no that was funny that makes me question
my life choices
what am i doing with my life what am i
why am i here
daniel are you um you've been in the u.s
for three years and now you've gotten
to meet some of the biggest names in the
chess world you played with them you
were in saint louis
uh you won the big uh k3 state
championship which i think was a big
turning point in your life
when you look back at whatever's
happened what is what has been like your
favorite moment so far
with so much going on um
calling my dad after i won mostly
i was with my mom at the time
that was the best moment
was this after the k3's championship the
state championship yeah
right after i i drew my game and what
did he say what was the first thing he
said to you
he's shouting he's like yeah yes
there we have that photo and tell me one
thing when you when you went into that
championship
uh did you did you expect
it to turn out the way it did um
so um
i guess yeah expect it to win
that's that's an amazing spirit i love
it that's super inspiring and
what do you think it was that set you
apart from the competition because all
the other kids were also working on
chess they also had trainers what do you
think set you apart
oh my talented the the work i put into
chess
but they i mean like let's say they had
the talent
but also they had
they had um the hard work but i don't
know maybe
i just played better chess yeah i think
it definitely did and dany we see on the
screen your book which is
uh my name is thani and i believe in
miracles uh
uh tell us a little bit about about
these miracles or how chess has what
what is chess's role in your life and
how has it impacted you
i impacted most of my life like i was in
nigeria
it was also very good but um
chess was uh it put me
um up more in the world
than before but chess really impacted my
life
you are an amazing ambassador of
of chess as well as what um
confident and support of family and
love and humanity can overcome
the most difficult adversity uh tani i
wanna you know because i've heard that
you're really good at puzzle rush like
you said
and we have sort of prepared some
positions
that uh i thought i could quiz you on
are you ready to see a little to solve a
little bit of chess
yeah maybe i'll play plus battle
battle with me after me telling you my
high score i'm sure you're feeling good
about that
oh maybe i could play nakamura if he's
now
maybe before that i'm gonna hand it over
to yas and peter they've got some
questions for you and then i'll bring up
the chest and let's see how good
how good you are at tactics okay um
hello peter lecko hi hi tony yes
hi i know how to speak to your accent
and also
i knew you like two weeks ago
ah okay very nice so sorry nice meeting
you
yeah but i think yaser already has some
questions and then i will take over
right
sure uh tony i just had a very quick
question for you first of all hello
uh how is the pandemic impacting your
chess game
are you improving yes um it's like
it's on like 50 50 like
when i don't when i have school then i
have less time to play chess i have to
do my homework i have to rest and all
that
and then i get like some time to play
chess but
like when i wake up when
there's no school order it's covered
then
it's like i start playing chess and
i pray then we do some
things and then i just start playing
chess for most out of the day
but i also rest and all that wow it
sounds
like you have a wonderful life i'm
jealous uh peter jump in
yourself please yeah i would like to ask
you tani
what fascinates you the most in chess
um tactics tactics yeah yeah because
i remember you know when when i also
started out that
there was always something that
fascinated me and asked me to do more
and more and
i think this is always very very
interesting and
do you have a favorite player a part of
hikaru or you just say that hikaru is
is my idol
um hmm a tough question
okay i say hi carlos my idol
tough question yeah sorry for that yeah
but such is the game yeah
it's always you have to make your choice
uh to be honest i would also not be able
to answer it's it's very tricky but
i just thought maybe you immediately
will answer from your heart something
but yeah if it's difficult then
just don't bother with it i don't know
who's my idol
yeah great great
all right i'm ready to solve some chess
okay i am uh going to
bring up some positions as soon as i can
i'm
struggling a little bit to get the
controls up before that
tanya i want some advice because i've
got a seven-year-old nephew who's
getting into chess right now
so if you could tell him one thing about
how to improve what would it be
focus on the moves
do not don't think much in the game
just focus if you find a good move i
know it's like
bobby fisher like this trunk player
says um you find a good move uh
find a better one but the thing is that
i think that
you find a good move like what's the
point of finding a better one
if you don't find a better one and just
wasted like 30 minutes on your clock
then you're probably gonna lose the game
it's like
look for a good move if you just know
that
i don't know if i'm gonna anything you
know if
i'm just gonna say this if you keep if
like let's say you use that um
uh data like that phrase as
like my idea it's probably not gonna
work if you
think of more than three or four moves
and you start to choose
oh there's no e4 nah knight d4
now c5 then you're gonna get confused
and then you're
probably going to pick the wrong move
it's like a 52
chance you're gonna pick the wrong move
so when you find a good move
you think it's like i guess it's a okay
move like don't spend
30 30 minutes finding the best move just
play the move and
move on so make practice difficult
right well that's some great advice to
make practical decisions on the board
and not keep looking for further stuff
danny we still have the chest for you
but that has to wait because the games
have started will you join us for the
commentary and give us your insights and
uh on these guys how they are playing
will you stay with us
yep i'll hand it over to yasinpita and
tani to
take us through the action for the next
game all right thank you
tanya and tony uh thank you for joining
us peter we've got
a uh a way of getting into a queen's
gambit
accepted uh tony are you familiar with
the queen's gambit accepted
yep i'm very very familiar i have like
more than 30 or
100 teams of this okay great
because we've got one of the greatest
ethereal theoretical
chess openings expert peter lego
who's going to guide us through the ups
and downs of this position peter
yeah first of all i have to say that i
very much like
dingling's choice because now that he
managed to equalize the score he
he had to decide what to play with the
black pieces and let's just
get back to the critical position after
move four
because here we had seen that uh in the
first game of two days match uh the
england after c6
lost a very very painful game to to
magnus and it was the big question
how he will deal with this situation and
he chose the vienna variation
and after vienna it felt like magnus
says
i did not really anticipate this i did
not expect this so i don't want to go
for the most principle more sharp way
and he goes for a playable setup with e3
a6
a4 not that ambitious but on the other
hand i recall that
magnus himself used this already a
couple of times with great effect
black played the move c5 bishop takes e4
knight c6 castles
and now we have some very important key
moment happening in this position
because
black has two choice whether he releases
the tension immediately with c takes d4
e takes d4 and then goes bishop e7 but
this gives white
extra options because the bishop is
already open so white could go bishop
g5 and in this regard
black first goes bishop e7 waiting for
white to show his cards yeah
if uh i mean white cannot develop the
bishop immediately and
he doesn't really have a useful move the
drawback behind bishop e7 is that
suddenly white has the option of playing
dtx c5
yes he has this option and magnus has
taken this option but
it's never really clear that does this
promise
more than symbolic advantage for white
in this endgame or
does white able to pose serious problems
for black
i remember uh in 1992 bobby fischer
hadn't played
a public game in 20 years played a
rematch
uh against his old foe uh boris baskey
in 1992 it's betty stefan
and in belgrade and it was like that
match
featured the this queenless middle game
quite a bit and uh boris baskey put some
pressure on uh bobby
um in those queens gambit accepted
positions uh
tani uh is this a is this a position
that you would like to play
and if so with what color
um i would like to play for white
and my ideas like to yeah i mean bishop
d2
first but like i don't know because of
after bishop d2 i think
black has h6 stop my idea of knight g5
and 94 right yes they try to trade more
pieces and get your bishop on the
c3 the a1 to h8 diagonal
sweet the long diagonal
now magnus played the move bishop d2
uh with those kinds of ideas you're
suggesting
and uh black knowing
now what you've just told us if i were
black i try to get my
king off the open d file
probably play king e7 what do you think
white should follow up with now
um
actually king e7 had been played it's on
the board
but it's no surprise anymore no yes sir
something it's gonna happen sooner or
later
exactly the king uh can't stay on
d8 forever and in this case
i must say i think it's it benefits
black
a lot that the moves a4 and a6 are
included
because um the the b4 square
is kind of a useful square for black in
the sense that
sometimes he might just put his bishop
there
and make sure that his king remains like
kind of safe
i don't know tony d do you think white
should
get ambitious okay tony do you think
white could play
a4 a5 and maybe put his knight on a4 do
you like that as a plan
um yes i do like it as a plan and also
it's a good idea to stop the weaknesses
of
b4 and um b4 with the knight of bishop
because when you're pumped on a4
like it just makes a look more of a
weakness okay because
um but when you play a5 and you get like
94 knight b6
then some of his pieces can't go to b4
and then you have like bishop c3 and
also you need to watch out for knight e4
too 94 too
okay what is what what happened in fact
uh
in the game peter yeah please
oh my goodness
you see tony uh peter and i have this
really big problem
we're we're afraid that the players can
hear us
and that when we make a suggestion they
go oh that's a really good move and then
they go ahead and play it
so you know we try to keep our voices
down and
we just hope that all of the good moves
that we recommend
they don't play so i recommend for like
when the online
online chess happens when there's
cameras and stuff
i don't think it's really effective and
um you need to like put
so they can actually see what you're
doing on your computer
so like face the cam they could see like
part of your
face like this right this way they can
still see you the same way
you look that way but then you also see
what's on the computer and you see what
you're doing
because if like you just see their faces
they could be doing something else on
the computer
and they're facing what they're doing on
the computer looking like oh they're i'm
looking at the board
but they're actually using a computer or
using a bot
to play for them so i wanted to ask you
about that what's your thought about
cheating in chess you know because if
we're going to play chess
online that's a worry right you don't
want to play against a computer you want
to play against peter
you want to play against tanya you want
to play against a human being
so what's your thought about you know
remote chats and
cheating in chats i think the online is
perfectly fine
but yeah they just like they have to
turn the camera where the camera
that they have is looking at your
computer
not your face your face does not matter
the computer
matters because you're just looking at
their face and
what's it gonna do like that's even
more of causing cheating what's it going
to do because you're just looking at
their face
if they look there well you're going to
blame them you're cheating right
you can't do that so you like if you can
see the computer
and like this
and like they're typing like why you're
typing man like stop
right okay cool um back to the game
peter
uh what what what has happened uh white
played the move a5
and black played bishop b4 saying well
maybe i can
snap off this pawn well it's uh
not even only about snapping but it's
the common reaction in this end game
that when
white goes a5 you're gonna go bishop b4
before white goes knight a4
okay and uh this is this is why
it's considered that this variation is
not really giving any advantage for
white
so very curious to see what magnus has
in his sleeve
he spends time it indicates that
he is not super confident i mean at
least he doesn't know move pen move how
to achieve believe me he knows the ideas
he knows this type of positions but you
cannot really go
around type of positions here because
it's very concrete you have
this pawn on a5 you have to deal with
this pawn
one of the main questions will you play
in a knight a4 or not
i believe and if he does play knight a4
peter
yeah then the big question is actually
can you take this pawn
for example you captured on d2 knight
takes d2
you take knight takes a5 and after
knight b6 you have the
chance of taking knight takes c4 right
then
knight takes c4 of the d i don't i don't
i
it doesn't look clear for me
square too yeah we sacrificed upon tony
to get our knight to
b6 that's a good square but is it worth
a pawn tony
yeah like the knight on f5 is word of
worth upon where if rook have d1 what
happens
look for d1 yeah
you can play it on the board yeah
peter's just catching up with you for
sure yes sorry
there was some technical message for me
yeah what what did happen after knight d
txc for loop b8
no we were just wondering uh first of
all is
in your assessment peter uh does white
have sufficient compensation after
rook f1 b1 the move tani wants to play
luke fd1 yeah
okay there is some compensation but i
mean if you don't have any direct uh
thread then i might be able to get out i
don't know with bishop d7 bishop c6
or i can try to exchange the rooks with
luke d8
i mean it it does not feel like white
has more than than a draw but
in this respect it's also not big
question than after bishop before how
magnus is reacting and he's taking way
too much time i'm not liking this
something something went not according
to plans
really sorry i'm gonna be peter
so it is very interesting and
um also the position i don't like it for
white why is magnus
thinking so much and uh i don't like
this for my class
you do it you're like you're a good
invitation peter is impressed
you know he gives you high high marks
peter if we're not going to sacrifice
the bond
then magnus says if he's not going to go
knight a4 then he's probably going to go
92 or
e4 what's the story oh my goodness
i was about to say 92 and i just looked
at my
uh board there and i saw knight b1
that wasn't a move we would have
expected what if just bishop back to d6
if you're back to d6 that looks like a
decent move
i mean i i guess the best is a draw in
this position
yes i have the feeling like uh magnus
had an intention to reach somewhere but
he he mixed up something and he didn't
manage to to get where he wanted i don't
know this
a5 bishop before knight b1 sequence
doesn't really strike me as the way
white can fight for advantage and
in fact look at this thing said you know
what i don't care
actually i anyway maybe wanted to
exchange the dark squad bishop
bishop so let me just play bishop d7
develop bishop deson had been played and
magnus goes luke c1
black black is perfectly fine absolutely
looks uh as long as black's king
isn't being harassed it's perfectly
happy
in the center the king on e7
guards a lot of important business
squares d8 d7
so my first impression
is advantage black i mean i played
the queen's gambit accepted quite a
number of years in my career
and this was this position that i see on
the board is more than acceptable uh
to me and what if bishop takes b4 and
rookie three
rook c31 yeah bishop takes a phone look
at c3
bishop takes a three years night back to
c6 but
but now it's still black to move because
look c1 was the last move
oh oh oh okay so imagine rook on
h8 tani to c8
what was your idea that you wanted to
show
um no it doesn't work anymore um
you you you you thought okay bishop b4
and rook left
but unfortunately bishop b5 yeah
there's a pin oops and
suddenly it's black for choice
oops and 92 i mean
it looks more of draw time every time i
look at the position it just looks
but doesn't matter but but doesn't it
feel to you tony
like black's pieces are more coordinated
a little bit more harmony
like the like white king is in a
potential background checkmate
situation that can't be comfrey yeah
magnus is not using my idea
he's like trying to find all the perfect
moves just find the good moves and don't
waste time
you have seven minutes left not not
enough time
so you feel uh yourself to be more of a
practical player
yeah just play the good moves and and
get on with business
right yeah because then you're like no
no no
i have one minute on the clock then
you'll be like ah now i have to start
playing classy you keep playing fast and
fast
fast and then you lose the game but if
you just played your good moves you got
time maybe your opponent
could have flagged or you could have
just had a simple draw
question for you tiny when you're short
of time
do you panic or are you calm
um
i'm mostly calm when i have like short
of time
um i mostly
start playing like immediately though
one move i see
like if it's a practical position i'm
down time maybe i'll take two moves and
think about it for like two seconds
that's it but then i just started
playing my extinct
gotcha now i don't like when i had 54
in three and three minutes i had five
seconds left to get a 55
but then actually my instinct was
actually the correct answer
and the puzzle was only three moves
and like it says it's like the rating is
like three 3
200 and it's like three moves and
that my instinct was correct so i could
have gone 55 in a row
whoa uh tony i don't want you to give
away too much for your rivals in your
competition
but if you had to say what the best part
of your
chess game is what do you think it is
that you do
better than other aspects in your chess
game
how to convert positions how to convert
positions you're good at converting
yeah that's tough that's tough i mean
that's
that's hard by the way did you know that
magnus carlsen is giving away
for free an endgame chess lesson today
did you know that yeah you could get
a 20-minute in-game chess lesson for
free after this broadcast you could go
to
chessable.com
you can get an endgame lesson by
arguably
the greatest endgame player of the 21st
century what do you think about them
apples
that's good that's good okay
if i were to offer you a special
a one-time only uh fee
for magnus carlson and gave just lesson
a discount no i'm teasing
uh are you saying are you are you suppo
like where'd you go he played rook hc8
oh yeah i saw the broadcast there's a
bit of a lag there
oh okay so he did play the move
that we expected rook hc8
and i don't know tony it sure feels to
me
like magnus having lost
game two is on the back foot in this
game peter your take
of what we've seen so far
yeah i'm a little bit uh surprised i
mean also by the speed yeah
both players are taking their time and
one cannot really say that this is an
incredibly sharp position on the other
hand uh
both players have to make sure that they
are very precise because
uh i believe that if white does some
inaccuracies he might even end up in
some kind of a trouble and in such end
games if you end up in trouble that's
that's very bad news uh but uh that
there are certain aspects i mean this
pawn on a5
is a weakness so white has to make sure
that his knight somehow don't be b1
after the exchange
on d2 lands on b3 for example
immediately white gets comfort by
protecting the pawn by the knight also
eventually white can jump with the
knight to c5 targeting
black's b7 a6 pawns
uh it's it's not about finesses and it
might
not strike as a position which is so
complicated but it's it's very complex
and magnus has played the move bishop f
on a very nice prophylactic move
another route is to to try to get a
knight to c4 which would have the same
effect
protecting the a5 phone and maybe also
aiming at the b6 square
just to clarify what you mean by that if
black
captures on d2 and you recapture with
the knight
then thanks to this move bishop c4 you
just vacated
the c4 square and you're much more
active there than on d3
i i don't i don't
feel i don't like the position for white
more
more because i mean can you go back to
the position where
there's no trades because i don't think
ding is gonna do it
okay that'd be a surprise if he does
but i mean more of black's pieces are
more like
more together yeah like 94 just played
hmm
but i gotta ask you a quick question
tanya
tani uh did what about rook c6
ooh i was i i wasn't fast enough
what do you think white would have done
after rook takes c6
92 wait
92 but then you just free right
but wait go after rook c6
takes yeah take
yeah and then knight takes f3 ah the
inter mezzo knight takes f3 check yeah
it looks like ca
right that would have been it and then
black as superior has a superior
position for sure so
that was why more said god the two
bishops
mark it as it went
all right um very confident there
and you said you're good at converting
you know that's the hardest
part of chess is winning one positions
that is that's really tough you said
that you're good at doing that
but it is it's it's a skill uh
to be able to do that well tony
and the king side is just open too think
and play
all that but um okay so it's knight b4
and knight takes d10 okay
they trade off rooks they did yeah this
okay i have this bitter feeling
that they're going to get in a position
where
someone is going to be winning and then
back down losing and winning back down
losing
and then the game is going to end as
madness winning
that's it chess is a simple game right
you know two players sit down they have
eight pawns and eight pieces
and after pushing them around on the
chessboard magnus wins
it's that simple uh but tony i mean
seriously uh
check it out that pawn on a5 it's very
vulnerable isn't it
yeah like if like let's say they trade
off
the knights and then i think it's almost
losing because king d6 king c5 king
before
king dixie 5 and like the pawns
the palms are on the dark squares but
that helps blacks more
that help that helps block more
even if like but i mean the bishop was
on a light square it makes sense but
it would be better if the pawn was on a3
because it's like hanging right now
right but you can't move it backwards
unfortunately
now uh from black from black's point of
view
i mean uh he just needs to get his
bishop
on c8 in the game and do you like the
move that
uh ding lyrin played e six e
five
okay um
i think that oh yeah
yeah i think e5 is the only move because
let's say you wanted to go like
king d6 and the knight c4 chat and this
is a
nice trap that um pd6 knight c4 king c5
nice travel of knight v6 the bishop is
trapped precisely and so that move
e5 that opens up the diagonal
yeah yeah the game i played earlier
today had that same
type of um attack and i won the game if
knight b6 and the bishop were just
trapped
my opponent wrote in chat like man how
did you find that
sweet peter your take on the position
yeah i mean i think i think it's a very
very dangerous situation for magnus
because
it's such an endgame if something goes
wrong
then and you might be lost and it
doesn't matter who you are
uh there are not that many resources and
after e65 with
black bishop going to e6 knight going
back to c6 targeting this a5
phone white needs to find some very very
nice
way to to neutralize this and it's it's
not easy to
to spot that and not only that peter
just
uh you know it's not just the question
that okay i got this
ugly weakness on a5 it's also that
black's pieces are just more active
especially the king exactly i mean okay
this king on e7 is a monster
first of all as also tony mentioned
the king was very important because
otherwise white's knight could have
entered and black's bishop could have
been in trouble
but with a king on e7 it feels so
harmonious and
this e6 e5 would have been a typical
magnus move from the black side and we
would be praising that
wow of course magnus plays a move like
e5 automatically
so let's also give credit to his
opponents because
that's the point if you get a good
position then finding good moves comes
much more easy and uh you remember i
talked
right from the beginning that i like the
choice of dingling because if
that's what magnus got against the the
vienna variation then
why being at all went for any kind of
complications in this
uh and anti-moscow variation if if he
can get such a
nice position so i'm pretty sure that
magnus will never
repeat this valuation anymore in this
match but
actually if dean can win this game then
he can
start a great comeback no question about
it and
he captured on e5 and tony jump in right
now
this moment imagine you're imagine
you're black
imagine you're playing the world
champion magnus carlson
a hundred and forty thousand dollars is
in your pocket if you can win this game
what would you do right now for black
well black if i draw the game what
happens no you got to win it dude
you know what i think i feel like i'm
just down the pawn
good good good start good start keep
going
so how you gonna get it back a 96.
yes very good and the knight going to c6
forks the pawns on a5 and e4 so what
about white's knight c4
how are you going to get the 140 000 how
are you going to win
back the pawn
bishop e6 very good and peter you jump
in how do you
uh rate ding lyran's chances
after 96 okay yeah i i think i have to
go
for this knight d6 and we will see some
very forced variation knight takes a5
white is gonna go e4 black goes back
knight c6
you take on b7 i take on b4 and this
knight on b4 protects the a6 pawn this
is
i think uh the big problem white is
facing
and i don't know exactly how to improve
white's place
knight c5 knight c5 and then
a5
so at the end of the day tony
uh it's black who has the
um i want to say better pawn structure
right
the double bond and keep fighting
before of course we never stop fighting
that's what uh grand masters do
we're warriors tony yeah and this
actually happened in the game knight c4
bishop e6 and magnus chose the move king
f2 so
he wants to make sure that when black
takes back the pawn on a5 then he gets
his bishop to d5 yeah this this should
be the
the concept of magnus so we went king f2
basically inviting black
that okay you cannot really strengthen
your position you have to
take sooner or later on c4 if you want
to get the pawn back
if you take knight a5 i gonna go bishop
d5
the big question also okay but after
knight c6 if you go knight c6 you are
not threatening anything yet
and you can't really move this b7 pawn
because uh
then the knight is hanging and if you
take on e5 then b7 pawn will be hanging
this is the defensive method of magnus
indeed and we have seen what you just
said peter
a trade trade and bishop d5 and knight
c6 on the board
so the players are catching up to us
tony uh an important question
for you do you think these players
are cheating because they find all the
moves
that you and i and peter have found
i i mean
or are they just that magnus become a gm
how did he
progress online did he cheat no i don't
think so no he didn't change
no i don't think so i think i think
they're just really good what do you
think
and they're also better than us right
okay maybe they're not going to pick our
moose but
we have the engine with us come on
exactly
now peter i think everybody on our panel
is in agreement
that black is for choice but is it
serious
yeah that's that that's exactly the
question and
i'm a little bit surprised by things
knight x e5 bishop takes b7 a5 of course
it's a very safe choice you know that
you are a little bit better and
you are running no risk i was just
wondering if
anything like knight d8 you know it's
slightly passive move but i got this
pawn structure and then
trying to advance my pawns maybe to b6
and then to a5
activate my knight via e6 to c5 keeping
this this kind of pawn structure with my
extra
queenside pawn i felt like it's more
ambitious
but okay i don't know what dink has in
mind
i i agree completely i would uh
i would have been incredibly reluctant
to trade off
for this doubled e5
pawn that's kind of isolated uh for that
really good looking pawn on b7 so knight
d8 v6
that definitely got my choice and
he's just played this move g5 and it
does
trap white's canyon a bit it white's
king is in a bit of an
unpleasant box uh on the king's side and
i can see ding lorraine wanting to go
king d6 king c5 king before
tony that was a maneuver you mentioned
heck 20 moves ago
now i think they're cheating
because they play so good no they keep
playing our boots
that's what i'm talking about you see
we're the world captains
right yeah they're peter they're me
there you go and peter uh
maybe uh dean made the right choice
after all knight takes e5
well if it's better or better than the
other i don't know but
definitely i know as a player that once
you spot such an idea that okay you take
on e5 you go g5 and you run with your
king to b4 and it looks very
very nice then you might simply not
think about any other alternatives
whether being really chose between
knight d8
and knight xe5 i'm not come completely
sure
in any case it's a very interesting
position because
i mean white has to run with his king
yeah
king f2 king d6 kingy to king c5 had
been played another big question is
that after king d2 can i play knight c4
check is that an option for example
yes you can force uh definitely a king
upon end game
and tony have you uh practiced your king
and pawn end games
uh do you know if this is a win for
white
or win for black or draw
wait um
you know the professional answer in such
moment is that it looks dangerous
it looks dangerous nice
i didn't realize that that was the
professional answer
i've always heard it looks interesting
i have no way no way
holy smokes bishop b7
magnus was maybe afraid of the king and
pawn end game
and that looks like a terrible move to
me because
doesn't that allow black to oh you're
about to play king c4 i didn't even see
that move
i was thinking knight c4 and to force
the pawn
on a light square i would have thought
that would have been
you know really bad well yes are you
canadian
sorry are you canadian how dare you
connie of course not i'm america
i mean i've been playing for the u.s
olympic teams
before you were born it's incredible
like hey
like holy smokes
that's because i do too much streaming
with amman
and eric hanson surprise now they're
canadian and i think they're rubbing off
on me
tanya welcome back hey
assassins popping in to tell you that
the world champion is in
a lot of trouble right now and you are
on the money with your suggestion of
king c4 he has gone a4 but king c4 was
was close to game over for magnus and
i'm not sure what he saw but let's take
a quick look at this lion king d2 has to
come to defend the pawn on b2
you go king b3 king c1 knight d3 check
king b1 you take on b2
after bishop d5 knight c4
and you pick up the f7 pawn but the a
pawn and the king moving on to e3 g2
with king c3 king d3
these threats are too powerful and it
shows that
black was completely winning on this
line a4 still keeps some advantage
but now white has the opportunity to
come back
into the game
thank you for that tanya we've just seen
in fact king
to d2 and allowing a knight for peter
and also tanya it's tony and e
tani and
kanye connie yeah
my name is
i'm sorry but this also looks completely
winning for black
peter i mean it's just an extra pawn and
i everything has gone wrong for magnus
in this game
yeah i mean okay the the whole point was
that with this pawn on a5
uh you just don't have the freedom i
mean it was clear that he mixed up
something and
then he had to go back to the knight b1
i also liked the way how dingling
continued the game because it looked
like it's a little bit premature that he
was exchanging all the pieces
but in fact he had foreseen that after
changing all the rooks
then his king on e7 already the king in
the center
combined with this e6 e5 ideas he will
have excellent chances
and yeah magnus in a lot of trouble his
only chance is that
thanks to his bishop and the reduced
material
maybe he can hope to survive okay
and uh uh tony
you said you're good at converting if
you were black
would you be playing fi f4 and
rushing ahead or
how would you convert this
position um
i it doesn't look also
that good but i think the only way to
convert this position let's say like
black goes knight f1
and of course you have to go g4 right
like knight h2 okay yeah just establish
right three bishop ca
i think the main idea is that
bishop like you go bishop f5 and it's
more
like you're stuck in the position but
also
black ass also has this idea like king
d5
king d5 maybe sack of knight king's g4
and f5 and start pushing your pawns
exactly so you think that
would go yes i think that blame brush by
five is a mistake and then you just have
to leave it on
see if it if like king comes to c7
just go to bishop five because then if
he goes d6
and then you go back and
yeah i think that's the only way to keep
the vision safe
yeah the problem i'm having time tony is
in this
kind of sequence that you've mentioned
the pawn on f7 isn't playing
a great role and i'm thinking that you
might want to
push or push him baby you know get the
pawns up the board
what do you think about f5 get it going
here you are threatening knight f1
yeah so probably after f5 anyway white
has to go bishop c8 one of the things
uh i would really like to have in this
position this black
pawn from a4 to move back to a5 yeah
right then then i would feel that it
would be kind of elementor technical
beam but with
with the pawn on a4 i feel that
white has white has chances to survive
and knight f5 had been played forcing
the pawn to g4
yeah g4 played knight gets back to e3
so expecting some bishop c8
i i'm sorry uh peter could you just
show that one line again with f5 because
i really thought that that was just a
winning decisive move
i thought your bishop c8 was forced
and i thought knight d5 check would come
as a kind of a blow
the king has to move then you go 97
exactly
and then bishop king b4 exactly
or not this but maybe i get kanta play
with king d4 no
exactly you do i apologize this is
this isn't i'm not converting tony i
need help
i need help
what has happened in the game uh peter
yeah so we are having this is the
current position
g4 knight is the bishop fc f6 had been
played now king dc is played
and both players exactly equally done on
time
i mean one and a half minute each
and after king
d3 knight c4 has been played king c3 has
been played
and i'm assuming knight e5 bishop d1
king b5 or what do you think uh
dingleran has in mind peter well to be
honest i'm a little bit
confused because i spotted this move
king c4 as tanya mentioned computer
said as well that it's it's winning and
it looks so natural because the bishop
left that diagonal and
you could enter that now i have the
feeling that once
black miss such opportunity then somehow
this game
most probably will end in a draw because
that's that's how you you get punished
by
missing your chances usually but still
okay black has still the chances to win
but i i would put already my money more
on draw
aha and how about you tanya do you see
uh that ding really missed his chances i
mean because we've talked about
his missed opportunities it's almost
painful when he
he misses his chances huh
yes uh peter is absolutely right
about ding having messed up his big
opportunity and in fact
a4 was not was not the end of the world
he still held a lot of advantage but the
way he handled it with
pushing this pawn to g4 and now this
particular position that we have
most of the advantage has been blown
away by diglerin and after a move like
king d3 he's gone bishop g2 but the
thing is that it's now
really difficult for black to be for
black to actually break this position
without trading
too many pawns and i think this pawn on
a4 this is the critical point of this
whole thing
that having the pawn pushed to a4 was
perhaps uh
perhaps not the best decision because he
had to play extremely accurately after
that because in all lines the white
bishop will be able to attack this pawn
on a4 which is why it was much better to
have it on a5
uh the computer doesn't give a huge
advantage to black of course black's the
one pushing
but i i do not i think it's going to be
extremely hard for dings especially
given the time situation to be able to
convert this now
thank you for that tanya and
tony now we've got this kind of a
similar situation you had
you'd wanted to chase the king towards
the g4 pawn
and ding laren is going after the
b-2 pawn in your opinion has ding loren
made the right decision
right call
he's going to the i i don't think he
made the right call
because mostly then the
the g4 pawn is um more the
just stuck with the f6 and g5 pawn
but now you're king d4 yeah now this is
just a complete jaw already the
computers are giving
as an evaluation that black has got no
advantage and this is the point he has
that black can never run after the b2
pawn anymore because of this weakness on
the a4 pawn which black white will
always keep an eye out
and white's king is rushing towards the
pawns on the king side
um making sure that they don't get
anywhere um
all advantage big opportunity lost by
dinglaryn in this round
yeah that was a big mistake he should
have won for the g for pawn
yeah in fact because i think like
sacking
like then like maybe your king can go to
like the
b2 or a4 pawn a bit so that there's no
queening that fast
and then the pawns from f5 and g5 just
start running up the board
you ain't stopping them okay maybe you
have some [ __ ] five ideas but
then the king can run
peter i gotta feel man i i feel terrible
for it being loren because this was such
a pivotal game and such an
opportunity to win the set
wait what happened wait
after i have five politics in g4 k5
g3 bishop g2
came up with this very nice tactical
shot of bishop takes a4
because his king is just too active and
the knight will not be able
to to protect the pawn wait there's no
way
right yeah it's really sad
tani there's no way and again peter i
just wanted to
get your thoughts there on what what
what a missed opportunity
this could be awesome now ding is down
by time
yeah you should have just gone for the
good news
yeah i mean okay the game actually just
finished in a draw
yeah i mean what i wanted to say
absolutely fully agreed because
i mean he won a brilliant game in game
two
so he came back and somehow it felt like
magnus didn't know how to deal with the
situation what to play for
uh ding made the right choice in the
opening got magnus out of his comfort
zone the magnus was
heading towards endgame which usually
suits him but
with this pawn on a4 and the weakness of
the b4 square is
is not the type of end game magnus
really likes he likes when he has
everything
under control and he it was not the case
and then he somehow made some nervous
decisions and
being played the perfect game it looked
like he's just about to win
when he missed this uh win with kings if
we as tanya has mentioned
right and tanya i think we have to thank
our guest
for uh coming on the show sharing his
life story and
showing us
the tactics thing yes uh i think we're
going to be going on a break so we do
have some more time with dany danny
we're going to come back to that but um
i'm not letting you go before you show
us exactly what you got but yes let's go
back to that very
important we're going to bring this
tweet up in a bit but yes let's go back
to that position where we had king c4
because i think there's a really nice
subtlety and why king c4
is so strong after king c4 we saw this
line with king d2
it's all forced because otherwise it
just you lose the b2 pawn you have to
come to defense
and after knight b2 bishop to d5 knight
c4 bishop f7
and the whole point is that after king
b4 the e3 pawn actually falls by force
and now there's no way to defend it if
you go
e4 knight d to check picking up the e4
pawn
bishop c4 is a is a lost kingpin ending
and because this pawn falls the
a5 passer is what you want to create to
be able to win
this game and again a4 in fact it is the
second best move
second best choice of the computer
maintaining the advantage but the
problem with the move like a4
is just simply how committal it is with
very short time on the clock
you have to play accurately it's still
winning for black in certain lines but
so much accuracy is required because
white is always hunting down this pawn
on a4 with bishop c8 bishop d7
ideas and i think this was um like you
said peter a big
opportunity by dingler and miss after a
really stunning game actually
the way he traded off the right pieces
in the middle game
after 94 trading of the minor piece
trading off the
rooks off the board i think it was
brilliantly played by by ding
with just a heartbreak at the end and
this just shows how difficult
chess really is um tania are you ready
to show us how difficult chess really is
or not
no i don't want to show her
come on you can do it toni
yes i like that i love it okay so
um i'm gonna pull i'm gonna pull a
position up so
i thought that we could perhaps go
through some really interesting moments
that we've had throughout the tour danny
where
we've had some really um tactics which
have
sometimes been missed sometimes not but
stand out moments and let's see if you
can spot them
or spot what some of the grand masters
and some of the top players
actually missed so first up give me a
second i'm going to pull it up
all right let's start with this one
and if you've seen any of these
positions before you've got to tell us
okay because that's not fair then
all right so you see the position on the
board
sorry one second i'm just gonna pull it
up
uh you should be able to see it now do
you see it
right yes so white's just gone um black
played real cafe and white went rook c4
and wants to pick up the knight on b4 if
you pick up the bishop would you what do
you think about rook c4
isn't rook f7 your free piece why is it
a free piece
it's before queenie one okay fine i get
it it's really easy but here's a little
thing for you all right magnus actually
missed this and this was a sensational
moment that hikaru nakamura
in the armageddon game actually that's
how it happened dany that's exactly how
it happened
uh hikaru nakamura played queenie one
check picked up the rook on b4
and advanced to the linderis abbey rapid
final by beating the world champion
blunders happened all right let's move
on that was that was just a starter one
made it easy you ready for round two
yeah okay
all right so here we have it and this is
uh
white to play it's between its uh fabi
against anish
and how did the what would you play with
white hair
you'll play what rook g5
and you haven't seen this game before
nope nope
what's your idea rick h5 in me
damn all right and that was what was
played and that's exactly how anish
wrapped up this game
and of course in this position white
could also have gone queen g5 and picked
up the f5 pawn maintaining an advantage
but rook g5 is just
such a stunning construction and there
is no way
nothing that black can do to avoid rook
h5
king h5 queen g5 check all right tani i
am
um i'm impressed let's move on you're
you ready for the next one yep
i feel like these have been too easy for
you let's step it up a little bit okay
two for two two for two yeah all right
this was between hari krishna
you've seen this no i've not seen it
that's
it okay rook rook a4 knight a4
queen a7 what happens after rook b4
because that move is there on the board
i know does queen eight matter
uh okay queen queen a5 where you could
just go queen
that's the idea that's the idea so
let's have that on the board and this is
again something hari krishna i'm sorry
actually hari played h4 in this position
but it that's
that was the whole point here hari went
h4 and missed
this golden opportunity where he could
have actually wrapped the game
up against the world champion and queen
a5 is what he um
he i i had a small talk with him uh
at some point after and he said he
actually did not see queen a5
in this position missing this all right
danny on
a roll we still got a few minutes so i'm
i'm still struggling to give you
any any fight here let's see what else
we can
we can find okay this one's like mega
easy and you're probably just gonna
laugh at us but i'll still put it up
what do you think like you've got five
seconds would you play rocket seven here
what would i do would you play rookie at
7 with whitetail
what do you think about 87
87 yes
no why now you want me nah nah i'm not
gonna do it
you're not gonna do it but uh tani
that's exactly
what the way he did against kari sergey
karjakin
and actually lost now oh my god
you entered seven and 91 made and this
was game oh we've had some
incredible make mistakes we all make
mistakes
we all we all make mistakes this is true
okay now let's bring up
the this one's a tough one this one's a
tough one
all right black to play
black okay
give me 10 seconds
is the visual cheats here
i don't even know what this is annoying
okay so bishop g2 what happens after
bishop h8
yeah queen h3
i wanna i wanna be i wanna be tani when
i grow up
okay last one before i let you go and
this if you you might have seen this
because this is super fresh in all our
memories
uh it was from a game yesterday so if
you've had have you had a look at this
position
no all right so uh yeah here
uh white to play magnus wine rook f3 um
what's the what comes to your mind
let's take a look at what happens here
f7 king f7
26 all right king g7
queen
queen e7
it's uh it's interesting you say this
because this is the line that peter and
yaz were also discussing and then after
a long time i think we found
peter found this resource of um rook87
and keeping everything under control
and um
you were absolutely right but here the
correct move is 97
and there was no way to defend the g6
pawn
the world champion went on to win the
game but it was a pretty tactic that he
missed
now that's like really i see now where
your puzzle rush score comes from and
where your attacking instincts come from
uh we are going to be starting our next
round soon so we're going to be saying
goodbye to you but before you go
i have to ask you what is it that you
would you know
danny you've inspired so many people
across the world your story is
just just incredible and also the fact
that
you know after i think the one thing
that really struck me was
that after the gofundme campaign and
with the big success that happened with
it your family decided to use that money
to help other children and similar
other families in similar cases who who
were refugees in the united states uh
what what's your message to everybody
and what would you like to say to all of
us
uh before you leave network style and f
talent does not have hard work
sorry repeat yourself tawny i missed it
hard work beats talent
if talent does not have hard work
all right wow tanya i i still can't
believe you're nine years old and this
reminds me of
of an article that i'd read in in the
new york times
by uh by nicholas kristoff and he said
that
you know opportunities are limited but
talent is universal
and when there's talent everywhere and
hard work like tani's put in
magic happens thank you so much tani for
joining us and
it's like he's watching can we play
puzzle
now yeah can we play first battle now
if he's watching there you have it
hikaru an open challenge from tanya who
also believes that he'll beat you in a
best of 10 match all right tani all the
best and thank you so much for joining
us you are an absolute
rock star thank you bye thank you danny
bye bye thank you tony bye bye
thank you tommy bye
he likes uh imitating you peter
i understood it yeah but probably my
accent is just such a nice challenge for
for tani he just loves challenges and
maybe it's not even a big challenge for
him it just comes naturally
just by solving all these puzzles
positions
yeah it looked to me tanya like
tani is saying i can play with these
guys you give me these kinds of
positions
i can win them it was insane uh
yes and i think the one thing that came
across was just the confidence that he
has
and of course you can read up all about
tani on
um on chess 24 and um
uh there's a book as well that uh on
danny and it's called my name is thani
and i believe in miracles and his his
life story is really it really makes us
all believe in miracles and
just the impact that chess has on
people's lives and now
he he's just the perfect ambassador i
feel for this entire impact chess
uh story that we have for the magnus
carlson chess store
benefiting kiva final and we had arvind
write in with
wow who's this amazing prodigy kid
giving an absolute killer speech the
maturity is stunning
absolutely arvind and it's uh it's
incredible because when you think about
about just how much the family has gone
through and just how hard it is to leave
everything behind
and and move to another country because
you're forced to when you seek asylum
there and then just how
people come together and the community
can come together to help somebody
to help them set up and uh the love and
the support
that you can get it cannot be measured
that's that's just simply priceless
and uh with chess in that mix just magic
can happen
uh we've got games we've got liftoff
really soon before that happens let's
talk about the chess that we've had
i have to say that the last game that
happened yas
and peter is going to be
something that's going to be hard for
ding to forget because of course he
knows that he missed a golden
opportunity there and to be honest
ding is such such a masterful player
when it comes to technique
that i'm really surprised that he was
not able to convert it i mean
change the colors and i have no doubt
that magnus
would not have messed it up the way ding
did
yeah that that again that's a painful
mess
but tanya having said all of that i mean
they've been on a roller coaster ride
since day one
uh dane's gotta feel pretty good about
his chances i mean
we've got a set i mean uh dingleran will
have
white in game four and if he can win it
he'll force another set of games
tomorrow
yes uh indeed yes and uh he needs uh if
he wins it
that means we get another match tomorrow
if it's a draw we go into tie breaks but
of course if magnus carlsen manages to
win this game he
qualifies he wraps up his semi-finals
and qualifies
into the finals i have to say yes with
when you're playing against the world
champion
you know you don't get too many
opportunities you don't get you don't
get so many chances to win the game you
don't get so many chances of even
having a better position and when you do
you better make the most of it because
uh it's it's not going to come back
easily
absolutely i couldn't agree with you
more it's sort of like
uh you know when they're beating you
they win these world champions but when
you're beating them
if you give them a tiny window to escape
they'll jump right through it so when
you get these opportunities you really
got to nail them that was a big miss
but once again dingler in in here with a
shout
thank you tanya and peter uh oh my
goodness
i was just about to ask are we going to
see a repeat of the kings indian
and i wanted to say no
but i see g6 is on the board yeah as
magnus
pointed out that he used to be very
stubborn it seems like he is still
very stubborn no i mean he insisting on
on g6 but now with c5
is trying to mix the mix things up
and offering after the move c5 a kind of
a
g3 bononi possibly even a benko gambit
but d4 takes c5 i i don't know about you
peter but i always felt a sense of
relief
when my opponent played d4 takes c5 it
almost felt like
well he's not really trying to press an
advantage your take
yeah don't be fooled because this is
modern chess and one of the tricks of uh
tricks no tricks basically the new
development in this
whole variation with third move gc
against the kings indian gloom fell that
after c5 you are not forced to to go for
this uh
d5 benoni type of positions because then
one can argue that
once you have committed to gc those are
very complex middle games where
black has all the chances to claim that
he might be objectively fine
and the other option of playing knight
f3 is kind of known
not to lead anywhere and in this regard
it was very important and the big
discovery in the last couple of years
that
in fact after c5 believe it or not this
dtx c5
queen a5 check knight cc queen takes c5
and here the move i believe queen a4
is posing some some questions for black
wow i feel almost like chess theory
goes incredibly full a circle
because uh yeah back in the day i mean
a d5 after you play the move c5 uh
the move that everybody was terrified of
was d5
and so on and i i uh
i always you know just inwardly felt d
take c5
wasn't that great but then again wasn't
i playing
knight a6 peter against uh captures on
c5 i saw that magnus played queen a5
check
right away so there might be something
wrong with knight a6
uh i've yeah well
why i suddenly silent uh was silent
because
ding in fact has played the move bishop
ec after queen takes c5
a very very interesting move sacrificing
the pawn on c4
basically claiming that okay go on and
take it then
you're gonna face luke c1 and i'm not
gonna be
i'm not sure if you're gonna enjoy this
at all
just continue knight c6 i guessing
bishop
g2 and i i think you want the tempo
knight d5 and i gotta go queen before
or yeah or queen a6 just get the queen
out of the way yeah somewhere yeah
right i mean i know the there's the
catalan
upon sacrifice uh grand master
lev albert used to love to play upon
sacrifice like this
but this isn't a position
that i'm familiar with in theory and i'm
a pawn grabber peter i don't
quite get it yeah i think this is
typically the position that
you have to know and you have to have
checked with computer in order to
understand
why you can give the pawn because all
these lines are often
very mysterious so if you don't know the
follow-up then
basically you you can't really play this
this move
and i believe that somehow
think because he took like one one and a
half minute for bishop pc so it was not
like
he bleeds it out but uh i i believe that
he
must have seen it because otherwise uh
he wouldn't have played bishop e3 well
your move queen a4
is rather a prelude to bishop e3 and i'm
just looking at uh
the cameras of the players uh and
it's sort of like ding almost looked
like oh no i blundered uh
he's got his head in his hands and
magnus is sitting there thinking to
himself
okay like we've been on a roller coaster
ride today i mean we traded
blows i just got lucky in game three and
my opponents offering me a pawn
why yeah and he declined it
he after some hesitation played the move
queen a5 but i would say that
in this sense then white has gained
something
and this something might be of
quite in big importance yeah
um okay uh queen a5 uh
definitely one of my uh from
from childhood i want to say from the
time i started playing chats
one of my greatest pleasures was
developing with a tempo
i mean of course i want to capture my
opponent's pieces and of course
i want to checkmate my opponent but i
knew that when i was developing with a
tempo
i was doing very good things for myself
for my game and what you were about to
say peter i think was that
white gained a very important
uh development uh one of the keys i
think whenever you're facing against
fianchetto
is sometimes you get to play queen d2
and bishop h6
uh you know you get rid of your
opponent's uh dark squared bishop
and somehow this bishop e3 this gain of
tempo
uh it really feels good i i
like white's position i would sign up
for this
if i was in doing shoes what what about
you how do you
evaluate this uh situation
i think everything depends on some move
permanent variations because
if white managed to stabilize another
big question is
where do you go with your knight because
there is the option of just simply
developing the knight to f3 but
that runs into something like knight e4
this is a typical idea from black
and another idea is just to play knight
hd keeping
control of the e4 square because the the
the
white bishop on g2 is just beautiful in
this long diagonal
and you are planning to direct your
knight to f4 getting access to d5 so
let's just imagine a scenario that white
gets his knight to f4 castles
and settles in then white will have the
dream
uh set up here but the question is can
black do something can he harass
white's position with with some move to
be honest i wasn't
exactly sure how but being has chose the
move bishop d2 it's quite surprising
but also a nice move too first of all i
really did like
your knight h3 knight f4 a lot in the
many many
english variations uh
that way of routing a knight to d5
uh is is very very thematic
bishop d2 is a rather
way of saying that your queen isn't
comfortable on a5
and i always want to jump to d5 your
queen is going to go
all the way back to d8 and then i get to
play bishop c3
and force an advantageous trade on the
d5 square
um i must confess i like
knight h3 better than bishop d2 but i
still think that white's for choice
even after bishop d2 peter yeah but i
think the point is that being very much
wanted to anti-event knight hd in
later on but the problem was that if you
go
knight hc which you we want so much it
probably
allows black to use this tactical
opportunity with d5
and you're just not gonna get time to to
get the knight to f4
after a move like c takes d5 you might
have bishop takes hc bishop takes hc
knight takes d5 using the pin
and uh black might be perfectly
fine if i'm not blundering anything wow
uh i don't think you're blundering
anything the move d5 i i
yeah that's a stunning move i now talk
about playing in gambit style we talk
about you know queen take c4 now
something like knight f4 takes on c4
i can imagine this gambit actually being
favorable but d5 okay that was probably
the move that ding
uh that persuaded ding to first play
bishop d2
yeah because after all this bishop d2
look c1 are very nice stabilizing moves
and basically by making sure that black
cannot
use this uh tactics immediately to break
out
then he felt like if black has to slow
down
and black did slow down i mean rook c1
d6 had been played
navigate of course went for knight hc
that's the strategic
idea knight c6 knight f4 bishop d7 short
castle look fc8
so black is playing all these kind of
typical moves getting ready to evocate
the queen back to d8
and then try to play some a6 tripling
somewhere b5
but i think being classical players we
we like this position for white no
big time big time and normally speaking
you know you get some kind of a moroxy
bind
uh with c4 e4 and then you've got a
bishop on e2
that doesn't always have the most
beautiful say
in the position contrarily this bishop
on
g2 is really an annoying and a very
effective piece
uh i like white a lot i probably
you know the computers are probably
saying ah slightly better for white
i just think that in a practical game
it's just it's just a lot easier to like
white and
and a lot of this strategy is based on
moves like
knight d5 and bishop c3 uh i don't know
he did play b3 in the game i don't i
didn't know if you first want to defend
the pawn on c4 with the move b3 and he
did choose that but
i just feel like you know sometimes it's
not a
question of playing the opponent or uh
playing the match score it's just like
you want to play
uh positions that your moves come very
easily uh and this is just one of them
uh for me peter
again the engine is probably saying
slightly better or slightly better
something of that nature
but i like positions where i don't have
to think too much i know where all the
pieces go
and i have the easy life
yeah perfectly agreed and i think also
dinglian is enjoying himself very very
much because
throughout this match after day one of
course which went
like a dream for for him i felt like he
never really got the type of position he
did
miss some chances but those chances were
not the usual dingley then chances when
because we talked about this that he has
such a class he he has this
game that can put magnus carson under
pressure but
uh exactly like today we saw in the
second game
and in the the current position
these are the type of positions where
dingling can show his
absolute talent and be
really merciless so i don't know what
magnus is doing i mean
i would have definitely advised him not
to
get into this type of positions but okay
he
he got them i don't know what went wrong
in the opening vacuum the surprise okay
probably this move
sixth bishop ec came as a big surprise
to magnus and
yeah really if you haven't checked queen
takes c4 and maybe queen takes ifo is
not even possible
then during the game especially if it's
so much at stake
like at this because let's not forget if
ding managed to win this game then
he he ties the match and it will be 2-2
and we will have a fifth day between
these great players
deciding the the outcome of their match
so
a really low at stake and everything
goes
as we probably expected after knight d5
95 95 white played the move bishop g5
which
we are dreaming about to make exactly
no this is all again i mean
maybe the computer are saying blacks
okay black's okay but don't be fooled
this is a very unpleasant position in my
view
and i like white a lot i like the bishop
on g2 i
love the knight on d5 i like the pawn on
c4
so for for me i mean everything
white's in cruise mode and the world
champion is definitely
under uh stress for those of you who are
joining us late
uh we saw an exchange of blows and we
saw
probably again we've seen some great
games in this
whole with these um magnus carlson
tour finals that's benefiting kiva
we've seen some great games but do check
out ding ling's victory you go
wow that was really good and peter
what the heck we saw a 95 bishop g5
knight c6
i mean that looks like a logic glitch
there what happened
exactly i think it's a very nice
indication that uh
magnus is also very very nervous he just
bleeds out the move 95
we probably without thinking about
anything he just
so that his position is unpleasant so
what he should try to do
plea as quickly as possible put the
pressure on his opponent
at least on the clock if or at the
position is unpleasant
but knight e5 was brutally met by bishop
g5 and all of a sudden black had to go
back to c6 so
not only didn't we did not like black's
position but black even lost to tempe
from that position
being immediately used with queen d2
bishop e6 look fd1
increasing the pressure i mean even some
ideas like knight xe7 uh knight takes e7
bishop takes b7
followed by some queen takes d6 later
are in the position
i i just wanted to mention this
possibility but to be honest i feel like
white has such a powerful position that
there is no need to
to go for such tactics uh and besides
magnus has also sidestepped it with
the move queen f8 yikes yeah
and these types of positions one of the
things that again white
really really benefits nicely from
having his bishop on g2
is when white with the the superior more
active pieces
he gets a chance to crack open the
position when he wants
with the move c4c5 so i just
feel that you know along with his
active pieces more active pieces better
control of the game
uh white also has the wand and you're
you're mentioning these nice tactical uh
ideas peter of sacrificing
uh but also options of seizing the
initiative with c5
again i just i'm really surprised
something went
very badly wrong for magnus in the
opening this is this is not good
yeah absolutely not good i mean i'm to
be honest almost speechless because
after all this is a very very important
game yeah
it's i mean okay you could decide the
set
yeah exactly i mean if magnus survived
this game then okay if we will see a
playoff then everything is kind of under
control but if
dingley them wins this nice position
then he just wins the set and he
he ties the match and it will be a fifth
day and then magnus will really regret
after winning that very impressive first
game of today
that he led ding back into the into
business
exactly now i'll i'd love for you
uh peter if you would be so kind as to
take us down that rabbit hole variation
that you showed
97 97 bishop b7 and ding by the way
did play the move before just enjoying
himself but that's two pawns
and as you were about to point out
you're picking up an exchange but maybe
even
pawn number three that d6 pawn as well
peter
yeah i mean it was uh promising but as
we already discussed it looked so nice
for why the whole position that
you feel like maybe this is exactly what
magnus is provoking
and we all know that when suddenly
magnus gets a chance
then to fight back and create counter
chances then he is very very dangerous
so in this sense i fully agree ding's
choice he just ins
increases the pressure with b4 after
that magnus said yeah i can't
tolerate this bishop on g5 any longer so
let me go h6
white returns with the bishop to e3 and
keeps all the trumps in
in his hands i mean in his hand because
the the bishops i mean just look at this
long diagonal the bishop on easily also
eyeing
the the other pawn on a7 so it's not
easy for black to to play luke ab8
because then the pawn on a7 will be
hanging black cannot play a6 because
then
there will be a four coming on b6 and
white is starting to advance with
c4 c5 uh a timely c for c5 or timely b4
b5 depending if
uh black uh how black the x
very very unpleasant position in in the
immortal words of somebody
oh dear something has really
gotten wrong here peter and i'm just uh
uh
can we put can we put the world champion
out of his misery after a move like
king h7 uh what would being
uh ding's approach be just depending
upon on h6
may be allowing for queen d8 or i don't
even know queen h8 i
i really don't know what what what what
magnus is doing uh
how should thing play uh peter
yeah it's a good question because i
believe there are different approaches
even something like h4 could be tried
because just to hint that
you know what you weakened your king
side let me try to bother you with h5
and if
black would stop that with h5 then the
white bishop could simply return to g5
which was
really disturbing black big time yeah
so even moves like h4 on the other hand
you have to be careful with the move
like
h4 because it weakens the g4 square
and all of a sudden maybe black can try
to think about something like 95 which
hits
the pawn on c4 and then aims towards g4
attacking the bishop on e3 so those are
the moves like h4 you have to
you have to think twice before doing
that because
one thing you want to make sure that the
opponent does not get
any counter chances and when we are
talking about this even the move
f2 f4 comes to mind just to
just to restrict any kind of knight e5
and then i can maybe retreat my bishop
to f2
even maybe go hd kingh to myself
and just say you know what i i'm not
going to win this game slowly but how
you going to hold it
right if i just keep the pressure on
like an old master
please show me how you're gonna play
yeah the
the move f2 f4 at at first blush i think
for a lot of
amateur players they're saying
that move opens up my king and it blocks
my bishop and i
and i'm fearful that that move might not
be the best move but what
peter is saying that when you play f4
and you start to think about what
black's knight is going to do
and indeed overall just the overall what
is black going to do
whatsoever white on the other hand is
ready to go
as peter is mentioning bishop af2 h3
and king h2 and slowly slowly black will
be strangled there'll just be no play in
the position
uh besides the move f4 another
you know completely uh um
i want to say contrary way of playing
maybe it's not the best but also just
a4 a5 peter
yeah that's that's also absolutely
perfect idea because
again using the fact that the white
bishops are so far
powerful and this knight on d5 makes
makes it impossible for black to to
react with the move a5
which would be strategically desirable
against
this advance but the b6 square
is and look at this king h7 and bing
feels like
i maybe have the time to
i mean maybe i can do direct action and
after king a7 b5
knight e5 c5 bleeds dowed by being as if
he had anticipated the move king h7 and
he already
made himself ready for his with his
answer
well one of the things that you know if
i can get into
uh ding lyrin's mindset for just a
moment
is he knows he's got a fantastic chance
like right here right now because if you
look at
all of white's position and i want to
really emphasize this
both of his rooks he knows he's got
everything
beautifully into the game whereas black
is actually
playing the position the rook on a8 is
out it's it's not there the queen on f8
you know versus the queen on d2 he's
going down all of his checklist
and he's saying i'm better here i'm
better there better there i don't want
to tie break
uh maybe before today set
if you told me you know two blitz games
will decide the match maybe he would
have been agreeable
but not this game this this game
he now feels like it's almost an
armageddon
i mean if he can win right here right
now and to my mind when he's playing b5
c5
he's calculating that after d6 takes e5
bishop takes c5 he's hitting e7
uh he's putting the world champion in a
world of hurt
yeah i mean uh it will be very
interesting how magnus is planning to
fight in this position
and he did play the move queen eight
queen e8 wow
okay so um maybe there are
issues if we take on e7 but how about
queen b4 just
snuggling up protecting the bishop
on c5 so that there's no rook takes c5
kind of
counter chances and eyeballing the e7
pawn peter
yeah that's one option another move that
came to mind is just simply to
a4 a4 increase the pressure and okay
after the queen eight didn't really
change much so white has
quite a nice choice here the only only
problem by
or the danger what i felt because i also
spotted immediately this b5 c5 idea that
if whitefield not achieve
exactly what he he wants and with b5 c5
basically he wants to
to put an end to black's position right
and
it might work into to black's favor that
the game gets more messy more forced
and more chances because after all that
the structure has changed yeah
right and if black manages to get out he
will be fine the only pro
only question is will he get out right
only survive the storm that he's
currently uh facing
so a4 would just be a nice move
uh but i wasn't quite sure of the answer
to queen before sorry to be
a past yeah no i mean queen before of
course yeah it's
it's very direct only that somehow i
feel like
i understand many too many things are um
i mean not hanging with that that
wouldn't be the right word but
somehow it's a little bit shaky a little
dysfunctional i agree with that
but i can tell you if i go bishop takes
e7 and knight f6 in two moves
i will achieve perfect harmony
i will be at one with the universe
yeah what if i take on d5 okay now
unfortunately because of the c
file i i think taking with the rook
would be desirable but bishop takes okay
i'll fall for it okay
all right well i kind of pat myself on
the back for just a moment
i'll hurt myself i won the two bishops
yay uh bishop e3 uh peter
you got that okay close but i at least
got rid of this terrible annoying knight
on d5
you did you did you did uh it's just
yeah lots of uh long-term
feels like a long-term advantage but
certainly we're both in agreement that
magnus is under pressure he needs to
survive the storm i'm just
checking the clocks if i've got it right
it's about
well five minutes to six minutes somehow
i expected there to be a larger
difference in time
but uh not so so ding loren
has been thinking for some time so the
two moves we've been looking at are
a4 and queen b
four could ding be thinking of b6 uh
what
looks to you to be the most he's
calculating something very deeply peter
yeah that's for sure the the problem
with b6 and queen before played
by the way that if white plays b6 then
black takes on d5
that's that's the defensive resource
because then
after bishop d5 or 25 black has this
very nice intermediate move with a takes
b6 and finally he gets
rid of the problems and opens the
opens the rook and the rook on a8 the
one i was
uh reprimanding for not having anything
to say about the game is in the game so
uh so he was looking at some forcing
moves i'm not exactly sure
that it took him a while but he did play
the move queen before maybe he had the
same
reluctance that you were misgivings that
you were mentioning there peter as well
that
something's not completely in harmony
but now having said that
definitely magnus under pressure how is
he supposed to handle queen b4
yeah that's a very good question and the
very tough one i also feel like uh
ding was probably hesitating between
queen b4 and day four
he might have felt like if queen before
works then
this should be the most powerful move on
the other hand in order to make queen
before choice
he had to make sure that he is
definitely not missing somewhere
something
one of the ideas that also come to mind
can black somehow try to
play desperate with a5 try to use this
moment that
uh the queen is a little bit awkward
a5 okay so you're giving up the b6
square
that way i i try to look sorry i i'll
think about the the
your your proposal i'm trying to look at
at the faces of the players and trying
to feel
their the weird part is the guy who
looks the most concerned
is ding whereas it seems to me when i
whenever i look at magnus he's got this
kind of california pool
he just seems imperturbed at
the board like like nothing so a5
uh you propose uh peter okay i'll drop
the queen back
not to a discovery but say all the way
to b1 i i want to keep the a
part of me i want to keep the b5 pawn
well protected
yeah i mean green b1
that's what i meant yeah i did weaken my
structure but at least i forced your
queen back
but if i was suggested out of
desperation and magnus actually chose
the
the defense i was first suggesting so
eliminating this knight on d5 because
okay how long can you tolerate this
bishop takes d5 and luke c7 played yes
i know and i agree that it's bad but how
bad it is
exactly i mean sometimes you just got to
do what you got to do
giving up the two bishops giving your
opponent these nice
nice um diagonals
uh if you don't have a choice you don't
have a choice so bishop takes d5 bishop
takes d5
rook c7 and uh
well because of the pawn on because the
pawn was on a7
i think i played bishop e3 peter yeah i
think that
that was quite annoying yeah i think
it's bad
it's a good question how bad is it
i don't know i mean i the engines
usually prefer the two bishops so i'm
going to say that giving white
a point a meaning a pawn advantage
i i know that you know sometimes i get
really shocked when i play
over a game after it was over and a
position where a player
isn't even behind material sometimes
they say it's a three-point advantage
and i'm like whoa
so i i have a hard time guessing how how
big an advantage white has
but i'm getting again i guess upon after
the middle bishop e3
yeah but you know what what you said
it's very interesting yes somehow this
modern engines i feel like
in the evolution there had been some
incredible inflation compared to
the 90s or the the 2000s because
i remember that when you worked with
fritz and with all these older engines
then plus two was appearing then
basically you almost had to design
and that is those plus two plus the
position often
happens that even a very good player
does not really understand
that why is that yeah and in this regard
i feel that yeah there had been some
movements toward this
increasing the evaluations maybe to
to make the engines even more attractive
but
i mean believe me often a chess player
just needs a plus one position which he
knows
how to deal with and he's more than
happy he doesn't need this computer plus
three positions which he doesn't know
what to do with
exactly and uh sometimes what you're
saying is
the simple clear logical uh
way of play is to be preferred over a
chaotic
plus three by the way i'm seeing a move
that never
crossed my mind rook c1 to be
won by dingler and and i'm going to
let you explain to our audience
why that was genius
i don't know why it was genius and it's
another question was it genius at all
because black suddenly got the chance of
playing e6 and maybe bishop f8 or
do i lose material because of some pin
yeah and e6 bishop f8 immediately bleeds
out wow and we've spoken about this
numerous times on these broadcasts i
don't know it's just
we're lucky or not peter but uh
eliminating those two bishops getting
them off the board
i mean magnus is practically breathing a
sigh of relief i'm not saying he's out
of the woods yet but
holy smokes that was a good trade for
magnus
yeah i mean definitely humanly speaking
for sure because
these two bishops were really so
unpleasant
they looked terrible and now magnus
going for queen g7
i mean vadilla has the feeling that
white has to win some material
right away because if not then just give
black a move like okay see it followed
by b6
and it's rock solid exactly uh the worst
of the storm uh is behind him now
he played rook b1 was his intention to
play i
i'm trying to guess here uh b7
b5 b6 i i just don't understand uh
the thinking behind the move rook b1 um
okay i'm at a loss peter uh
we'll just go with the play i think
we've just seen
rook be one to see one coming back so
it's like ding laren is saying uh
i want to trade off the
active pieces of my opponent so i can
attack the pawn on b7
it's confounding but there is a logic
behind it
at the end of the day the bishop on g2
is still
pressing yeah absolutely and now we see
that
magnus in order to keep the material had
to go
for complete defense with the look e7
look c5
f6 very very ugly but on the other hand
what he needs is to keep keep the game
going to hang
on as long as possible because after all
yeah queen c1 bleeds out look a8 also
bleeds
out the position is bad but
if you are not losing and you get this
b6 moving then
black has chances to survive and i would
say that
i would have preferred those two bishops
advantages more than
this type of advantage when yes maybe
it's uh
it's even serious advantage but
practically speaking uh
black feels that he he has chance and
it's much easier to defend this position
agreed all around uh now having said
that i do
also think that this position is still
in uh ding lyran's favor
how much though i mean okay on a good
day
he's going to go yes i was about to say
b6
and one of these days he's going to have
to go i don't know maybe something like
f4 and bishop c6 but
uh you got to win the game i mean you're
going to have to disturb
uh i don't want to say fortress but just
simply his setup
yeah also this looks it is already a
little bit interesting because
the point was that uh i believe that
white does not
necessarily want to change the pair of
rooks but if you
go back to cc i i believe i might had
the opportunity to call knight d7
using the fact that after look c7 i can
jump
with the knight to c5 and all of a
sudden everything is
completely different and i'm starting to
go knight c5 and after a move like
bishop c6
i maybe have the move rook c8 beating
you
and i know then i'm losing the f6 pawn
at the end
in in any case still it feels like
yeah look c8 is the right move
exactly not not to let this knight
somehow
to c5 well you you made such a
compelling
uh argument why can't i do that peter
rook takes ca queen takes c87
i mean i've i felt like that here
somehow white will
use the i mean we'll invade we'd look to
the eight and
simply you know i also believe the
players yeah that when they play and
they make their choice that
they think they have something behind it
right and uh as a commentator you try to
explain what is happening and
the the first reaction that i always
have that aha he played it
he played this move so probably this and
that he has in mind
and i like magnus's choice he went queen
efe he wants stability okay and
after queen f8 look they see it queen
takes e8 we see the move
f4 knight f7 played i don't know i
it feels to me like black is very very
solid
and i'm not sure i mean just as i
mentioned
exchanging one pair of looks wasn't
really
what white desired from this position
right
and i am saying again in my mind's eye
if i'm black again i just feel like
such a set this this sense of relief
that i got rid of some of the pieces
that were really putting on pressure
and okay not that the knight is great on
f7 i i like the knight on c5 as you said
but i am seeing that black is going king
g7 he's going e6 e5
and okay you get this great bishop on c6
uh
but it doesn't mean game over right you
just have a good bishop on c6 i can play
on the dark squares as well
uh in short i i i
feel that the advantage is slipping for
ding lehren
yeah absolutely and you know i'm i'm
even not really sure that
practically speaking he is any better
anymore because
uh black's play is so much simpler just
stabilizing king g7
okay i assume that white will put a
bishop on c6 and then later you can go
look c7 put queen on e7
i mean there are so many ideas
while white doesn't really have a real
entry
and look at this dingling down to one
and a half minutes so not only he
somehow misplayed
but he also clearly behind on the clock
right and again for those of you who may
be joining us late
uh this we are in game four of a set of
four games
uh the score is tied one and a half one
and a half world champion was in deep
trouble in game three but he managed to
save it
uh the winner of this game will win the
set and if it was magnus carlson who
wins this game
he books his seat to the finals if ding
larran
wins this game uh it means that we'll be
back tomorrow for the fourth and
deciding
uh fifth and deciding set of games
and finally should they draw then we're
going to see
two blitz games a pair of blitz games
to decide the winner of the set and
we've just seen the move queen c
six peter whatever i like
his choice very much by being i mean
let's not forget he's done
to 50 seconds on the clock so he also
has to make sure that
not he will end up with very little time
and all of a sudden there will be
complications
and after exchanging the queens
basically i think he makes sure that
he cannot lose this game and believe me
i believe it must have crossed his mind
because he knew that he was
so much better and then with little time
on the clock and some messy position
anything can happen but
like this he's in charge but i don't see
him winning
yeah i was about to say isn't it an easy
um well again magnus is the player says
i don't believe in fortresses
but i'm thinking that as soon as black
gets to go king e7
and maybe even i don't know knight d8 uh
i don't see him losing no not at all
yeah 98 on the board as
advertised so uh it looks
like this semi-final
no but hang on sorry to interrupt why
isn't white in trouble now
white in trouble why is white in trouble
uh
because oh you mean rook c1 just king
e7 to d6 exactly because e4
trying to meet king d6 with e5 doesn't
work because of
knight xc6 or rook takes c6 as well yeah
you just
you just you blocked your bishop
after e4 i mean oh
my word ah but okay very nice king is
the waterproof
i mean this is this is great yeah and
i'm very happy you know because it would
have been too much if if the ingredient
loses this and
and magnus moves to the final thanks to
this victory i mean
i have nothing against magnus going to
the finals but
not this way yeah a draw
and oh my goodness i i mean these last
two
two games i think for a lot of the
chinese fans are
sitting there going oh our hero
i mean he had game three he
just he just let it slip when he he
played this move a4 and even that might
have been
uh winning as well but i also feel this
game for just
man peter you know you just can't have
these many opportunities tanya
these opportunities don't come this
often and ding is squandering them
uh is this going to say tanya ah there
you go sorry i i
i think uh you you muted yourself
unintentionally i i forgot to unmute
myself that's what happened
i was talking about ding's play i think
game two was absolutely phenomenal
and he basically destroyed magnus's king
in that game and magnus played on till
checkmate and we've often
a lot of a lot of you have been asking
that how come magnus did not resign
earlier in that game i think a lot of
times what happens at the very elite
level and
at actually at every level when your
opponent has played such a
beautiful and a stunning attack you
almost acknowledge it by
letting the mate play on on the board
and i think we've seen these top guys do
that time and time again
uh of course they know that they're lost
and of course they know that the
checkmate is uh
incoming but they let it play out on the
board because
it's just too beautiful to not and
that's what happened there
also um we were talking about game three
and how that ending had
big chances for ding after messing up
with king c4
and then i had a look at chat and
obviously chat always knows best and
they kept saying that no in fact it was
not winning for ding at any moment and
um
cece said that it was it was uh it was a
draw all along and no real chances and i
had a proper look at it and chat you
are absolutely right you guys know best
uh we also had a tweet it seems
according to
it with zero point zero all along no
chances lost can't believe it
indeed this is true and of course it's
uh
it's amazing what these modern engines
how they can see so far ahead
and uh uh the evaluations and the lines
that they come across
but peter had a look definitely a4
itself was not
a great idea and probably would have
offered more difficulty for for magnus
if he would have gone king c4
but even in that eventually with the a
passer the computer does not find a way
to actually convert it too few pawns on
the board is what it says
and let's take a look at uh what
are the other conversations that we had
on twitter we are of course going to be
going in for the blitz very soon it's a
2-2 tie
i think um uh i i feel that
magnus is feeling a bit shaky right now
he's had three difficult games and
one he lost two he managed to defend
even the last game i think ding was the
one pushing throughout and having a good
position from the middle game again
not very clear where that big
opportunity was but a very pleasant game
out and all for ding lyrin uh magnus on
the back foot throughout till the very
end a nice
spot by peter with the defense of king
e3 in case black tried to go on with
king e7
let's take a look at some of the other
stuff that's going on on twitter before
we have liftoff with blitz
brilliant came to buy ding just curious
why did magnus let him make him
let him mate himself i mean usually they
resigned before that uh
intoxicated we will we were talking
about this um
like i said that a lot of times the
attack is so beautiful that you
let it play out to its end let's move on
we have tom writing in
it's not easy to interview children but
you were superb
with danny well done that should go up i
was not expecting that one on this
screen
and um well but thank you tom that's uh
very very sweet i think tani was just
an absolute pleasure to have and i think
the maturity he shows the confidence
with which he talks the way he
sees the way he was analyzing with peta
and yes absolutely not
intimidated uh with
with anything and you know just um also
the tactics that he solved the positions
he saw
he's got so much talent and i think with
the right support and the hard work
that he is putting in um a very very
bright future and i i'm looking forward
to seeing where he goes
i think very important years coming up
for him and i think
um yas can perhaps tell us more about
this that i'm sure saint louis is also
helping him a lot
and the united states chess federation
looking forward to seeing more of tani
in the future let's move on
great commentary love you guys love you
back
i hope we will have this kind of great
moment in the next days just 24.
yes like we've been saying that there is
a lot of more excitement coming your way
lots of more chess and i'll be giving
you more details on that
uh soon but uh definitely keep your eyes
out on chess24.com lots of exciting
stuff coming your way the tour is about
to end
but the chess continues the show must go
on let's move on to the next one
we had a brian writing in with could
anyone mention when the next chess
tournament is coming up
when the next tournament is coming up or
advice on whether there is a tournament
timetable available to us
um i'm going to get back on this uh once
i get
the update on and i will be giving out
some details at the end of our show
today about
what more is to look forward to very
very soon
uh let's move on to the next one we had
vishal
serene international master vishal
serene writing in i think magnus is
doing for chess what
gary what gary's dreams in the early 90s
making the royal game a pro sport
in the history of the future both names
will be up there
above everyone else when justice
discussed undoubtedly i think
i think we've got great players of all
times we've got world champions we've
got
legends but i i definitely think that
there's something that sets these two
gary castro and magnus carlsen just
um a notch higher it feels just there
that
dominating win after win their
performance after performance
gary and his era magnus now we've seen
them do it over and over again
and um i think you're you're right these
are
two players that will be spoken about
regardless just timeless chess from both
these uh
both these legends and
what else do we have we had lars writing
in
two yasam uh i'm sorry just give me a
second and yes this one's for you i see
that you are with us
um having worked with coach noy did you
grow to share is the state for this days
for the kings indian defense i read in
gallagher's book
that he loaded it with a passion and
that he spent decades
working to refute it any cautionary
king's indian
stories yes take it away with the ass
stories
well absolutely first of all lots and
lots of stories but before i get to the
stories and no
he didn't convince me no he didn't he
didn't convince me that the king's
indian was refuted
uh as much as he tried and you're
absolutely right he tried incredibly
hard
i still it's not that i'm passionate
about it but i
i played the king's indian myself
against gary kasparov
sacrificed my queen for two bishops made
a draw but what i wanted to
ask you um tanya was
to talk a little bit about the bar that
was
beneath you the kiva bar and
we seem to be doing well i mean we
started there was a lot of
white let's put it that way is it
we got a long way to go but then we got
a lot of green
uh tell us about uh the kiva
you are absolutely right uh yes we've
seen this bar that you see below me
uh going green strong and that's exactly
how we like it and this is all thanks to
our chess community to all of us
uh to all you guys out there who have
contributed to this
this brilliant cause of the magnus
carlson chest off finals
which supports uh kiwa's um appeal
during kiba's response during the
pandemic
kiva uh has been an organ is a
not-for-profit organization since 2005
they have been uh they have been doing a
lot for underserved communities
for businesses for entrepreneurs by
micro lending by
uh zero interest lending and helping
businesses
and entrepreneurs grow and their
startups thrive
and now we all know that during this
very very difficult 2020
it's exactly these isolated communities
and these isolated businesses that have
been hit the most and it's a very very
difficult time for them so in response
kiva
is raising money to lend out to these
communities to help them survive
the pandemic and come out of this and
what better
what better tool than than chess to help
with that because
chess 24 has partnered up with this
cause and now
you can invest in your education in your
chess education by going premium by
buying
premium membership either for yourself
or a friend or your family member
and by doing that fifty percent of all
premium membership
during the marcus carlson chess store uh
benefiting kiva final
will go to kiva's cause of helping
businesses survive a very very difficult
time so definitely consider going
premium right now
no better time you get unlimited access
to to the several
uh educational resources that are there
on chess 24 there are courses by world
champion world champion magnus carlson
has done
opening uh video courses world champion
vishyanan's done a course
grand master yan gustav sun's done of
course grandmaster peter swiddler has
done a course
it's how to improve your end game how to
improve your middle game opening courses
just all of that
unlimited access and we all have a lot
of time right now no better time than to
get better at chess to work at chess
and no better time than to
leave an impact on your community on the
community
through chess because it's now that we
need it the most and i think this is why
tani
tani's story was such a beautiful one
and he's just the perfect ambassador for
for our impact chess team because uh
i think it really shows how when a
community comes together it can
fight any adversity any challenge and
then
with chess it becomes it becomes magic
and it's uh miracles can happen as thani
himself said it so
definitely consider in putting in
by going premium for your own chess
interest to become stronger at chess and
also to give back to the community
support everything that chess 24 does
support chess
and support businesses around the world
uh which have suffered a lot due to the
pandemic
all right and we do have and i'm also
very very glad and very happy and very
proud to announce that we've got support
coming in from
so many from so many different um
different people and different uh
communities and different organizations
for this cause who believe
in what in the work that kiva is doing
and who believe that chess is such a
great tool to make a difference
we've had grand master peter lecco with
his generous contribution we've had
vasilevanchuk
with his generous contribution we've had
david martinez martinez with his
contribution
um magnus carlson himself saying that
he'll be giving out 10
of his prize money towards the cause and
now we also had
uni bet who are a big sponsor of magnus
who who will be supporting kiva's
campaign with 1 000 euros
and they will be gifting out the premium
memberships to
to the office bill chess club um
chess club members uh office build chess
club is also of course
magnus carlsen world champion magnus
carlson's chess club and
uh lots of kids lots of talents there so
uni bet has come forward
to donate these memberships to them and
in the process also helping out with
kiwa's cause uh be a part of all of this
because
uh i think i think no better time than
right now
and talking about no better time than
right now we've got a couple of minutes
before the blitz action which is going
to be absolutely insane because that's
the kind of chess that we've seen all
day
let's take a quick break catch our
breaths and we'll see you soon
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
so
so
welcome back and we are going to be
having liftoff with the blitz action
really soon and we all know how
our heart race is when the time on the
clock drops and when we go into bliss
we've got we've got liftoff so i'm gonna
hand it over a quick reminder that there
is the
world champions free endgame lesson on
chesapeal
visit that but for now let's go straight
to the blitz with peter and yas
thank you tanya peter we've got a we've
got a pair of blitz games each player
starts with
five minutes and they will get three
seconds bonus for each move they
complete
so they'll be going at a pretty healthy
clip and
thus far uh they're playing very
theoretical line of this london
take us through it take us through it uh
peter yeah thanks yasir
i mean the point is that usually and we
have already seen in their
first day match up they had this
theoretical clash in the london system
in the
in their blitz playoffs so
this time ding went back to his d5
setup however he wanted to make it as
concrete as possible because
it seemed like whenever magnus got his
structure he's feeling too comfortable
in these positions especially in the
blitz
so ding wanted to put as much pressure
as possible and he went for this very
sharp
queen b6 critical test somewhat risky
but
a very principal approach white is not
getting his stable
usual grip but it gets very messy and
very concrete
bishop b5 g6 played and
after that white castle bishop g7 knight
bc
and short castle played very very
dynamic variation our position
wow absolutely but i still have the
impression peter
that because there was such a a a nice
underlying logic
to the play from both players that i
have to feel that we're still in
theoretical uh territory
yes and and no because
see i mean i'm not sure how much theory
there is to this
and if there would have been so much
thought that i don't believe magnus
would have spent already so much time
but
but definitely the players must have
analyzed this uh position
that's for sure the question is when
this analysis
was done yeah because clearly ding came
to this game
ready that he gonna choose this
variation if magnus
goes for the london system and i'm not
sure that magnus
anticipated exactly this line from
dingley then
exactly now uh for a moment there
i saw i thought i saw that ding loren
had five minutes to magnesis four
and that kind of buttress is exactly
what you were saying there
peter that well maybe uh
the the the game had was better prepared
by
dingler and now he's just gone into
quite a deep think however with the over
the move bishop d7 because knight d4
obviously tickling the pawn on c6 is a
concern
and now we see this move queen d3 i like
black pardon me i like white's pieces
the black square bishop on e5 the knight
on d4
any queen trades and knight goes to a5
and man uh game over
yeah absolutely i mean this position is
very very tricky
but on the other hand i believe that
black has enough dynamics and yeah
knight e4 is played bishop takes g7 king
g7
very important for black not to trade on
on d3 because then
it's it's terrible so now magnus treats
himself on c4 goes for knight a5
this is okay black can capture the pawn
on c5
that there's a knight d2 possibility
yeah there is this knight d2 possibility
but do you really want to take this
exchange
no i don't i think rookney seven
but he has he done it he's done it yeah
exactly i mean they are blitzing out all
these moves i don't know
oh i would have thought that this would
would be terrible like as in really
really really bad
for ding lyrin i mean you and i have as
kind of
a magical belief in our minor pieces and
pawns when we're facing a rook
but this looks just wonderful for him
from white's point of view
yeah i mean i fully agree
i'm just you know shocked that how did
ding ding
went into this position i mean this is
this is insane
exactly it's just so bad because keep in
mind
white has already won one pawn c6 is a
goner i mean we're losing c6 is it
but the question is we might be losing
c4 as well
and if white if you put a white pawn if
you took that black
c4 pawn off the board and put a white
pawn there then you would ask yourself a
question
what the heck is that bishop on c8 ever
and i mean ever going to do you know
it's just like it's just there
and if you could imagine white playing
c3 with a black pawn on c4
white plays c3 and plays e4 as well and
again
the light squared bishop has no life
peter
yeah i mean what i'm even more not
liking the fact that
ding started to think once he went into
these segments because
i mean unless you knew how you're gonna
solve all your problems here
you just cannot play this position
practically this is lost
this knight on d4 is such a monster
because otherwise one could argue that
okay black can maybe just give up
everything and activate
himself with luke v8 getting rugby to
win and hitting the pawn on c2 but
hook b2 does not hit the pawn on c2
because this knight on d4
keeps everything intact and thanks to
this
basically rubi8 does simply nothing a
part of losing all the queenside pawns
exactly that's exactly the problem that
that black is facing and in the
meanwhile too
it's not like there's any where where's
the counter play
okay uh ding has seen an idea of rook
f8 to d5 uh peter
uh i've got a feeling there's a
refutation to that move
i mean i don't know if there is a
refutation but i have to say that yeah
probably it was the best
best move because at least black wants
something and it already felt like if
i mean it was not even clear what what
kind of black
i mean what kind of move black could
make yeah and at least with luke d8
knight atx c6 played luke d7 played
instantly
there is a plan of exchanging at least
one uh
one pair of looks yeah well the rook on
e7 definitely from black's point of view
you can't
tolerate that rook it's just simply
too powerful now having said that peter
i'm just wondering
uh uh maybe it's positional overkill and
i don't even need it
rook a rook e8 and somehow i put
i was trying to put the bishop on a8
right we trade
we trade rooks and then i go knight a5
and i was trying to put the pawn on c6
you know what i wanted
but that's the unfortunate part you do
have
that move just perfectly time to prevent
me from getting
this position which would have been
you know like one for the books you know
you
i want my name on this position peter
i can understand that yeah okay but uh
magnus has now gotten two pawns for his
exchange and he's just uh i think he's
just thinking that
you know he's been gifted a really
really great position and
maybe just thinks that he doesn't need
to do anything suspect
special maybe he should just take on d7
peter
and uh move his knight to either e5
or a5 and enjoy himself
yeah but magnus chose a different pet he
he kept the rooks
alive with rookie five i would say it's
the ambitious approach
most ambitious yes yeah rook c7 knight
a5
so basically he wants to make sure that
he gets this pawn to c6
just as you wanted but not allowing this
luke d5 counterplay
well then i have to say uh he
he when
he's been given a choice of something
but he's accepted both
uh he he gets his pawn to c6
and he maintains the rooks uh that's
it it's working out all too well for
magnus i i
i have a feeling this game just is over
before it got started peter
yeah i have the same feeling and you
know i can't wonder that
is this london system really so good
that you have to collapse i mean it just
i mean ding is such a great player i
don't understand why is he struggling so
much against this
london system it's not like that he had
been suffering in this game but
already in couple of games against
magnus he has lost many
very crucial games when uh actually if
he would have not lost against the
london system the whole match
could have been uh completely different
against magnus
exactly uh finally we did see king f6
and rookie
seven as um a dingler and wanted to hunt
down and force
absolutely absolutely force the trade of
rooks he has succeeded
but at such a great cost uh peter uh
two pawns down the c c pawn is still
lost king d2 c3
uh this pawn is gonna go to c6 and
um well i mean it it just looks
like black's position is some kind of a
a wreck
yeah i mean practically looking hopeless
i mean
you remember before we were discussing
that white might push the pawn to c6 but
maybe exactly now what black wants to
somehow achieve
in in order to i mean to get luke c8 c6
then he at least gets the king to c6 and
maybe to c5
i mean the position looks so bad that
even this doesn't really help but
when you have a bad position at least
you try to
look for what could at least limit my
damage yeah
exactly and and that's one of the
scenarios and yeah we are seeing that
the players are thinking the same way so
magnus went e4 rook c8
played c6 played
and here i can imagine that on magnus's
agenda is the move
c2 c3 the move c2 c3 not only
does it buttress the knight on d4 but
then
it keeps the pawn on c4 which in a sense
is limiting the bishop on e6
and well okay um
there is this also this nice uh
knight b7 check uh redirecting
the the knight by the way it's
it's like it feels to me if ding has any
chances
he's got to get his rook to b8 but
somehow hasn't he just encouraged the
knight to go
to a6 peter or is that asking too much
yeah i don't know it's a little bit i
mean at least after forcing the pawn to
c6 black got this
d6 square for the king it was very
important to time it correctly before
white advances the pawn maybe to e5 and
the king gets
logged on on e7 now we see some
repetition with knight b7
king c7 maybe magnus just wants to make
uh
win some time let's look at this magnus
is down to 17 seconds
i was about to say his clock has really
burned a lot a lot of time
and now he's feeling a little bit
uncomfortable
but again i want to just ask your
opinion about knight a6 he didn't do it
it looks like a draw has been
wow wow indeed
uh i really thought he was going to win
this game i thought it was
almost gifted out of the opening in the
final position knight a6 peter
what would have happened what's your
take
yeah i don't know what what what even to
say
what i'm thinking i'm thinking nothing
i'm just a little bit shocked yeah i was
completely sure that
oh my god being after missing these two
opportunities not gonna lose this game
and
maybe just exit the tournament exactly
after surviving this
now i feel like this match is still
keeping some
really intrigues yeah for us a real
rollercoaster
tanya we just we just don't know who
wants to win
today's set of games
i think both of them really want to win
uh yes but i think the
the points that showing up right now at
least when i was watching the players
when they were playing i think stamina
and energy
is really coming into question i think
both of them look
extremely exhausted and with blitz you
need all the energy that you can get and
it's something that the players
um i think magnus played a brilliant
game right now ding also
really good good sources but just in
that very end
coming down to seconds um couldn't
couldn't do it and i think even in the
last few games we've seen
things struggle converting or at least
posing the biggest questions in better
positions to magnus i really think that
energy and stamina is in play right now
and the players are facing this
really big challenge one more blitz game
coming up uh what an ending that was and
of course endings are never
ever easy to play and we've seen even
for the world champion especially low on
the clock
it can be hard but that happens rarely
with magnus we've spoken about this time
and time again just how strong he is
and that is uh why we need to listen
to when he and to what he has to say
when it comes to endgame play
so i highly recommend you go check out
chesapeal's
free lesson on endings given by the
world champion himself
it's a 20-minute lesson where he talks
about a game
in detail of the world championship that
he played in 2013 against vishyanan
and truly gives us an insight on how he
makes decisions
during end games in endings what is it
calculation
intuition the different concepts the
different themes that exist what is
important all of that's explained in
uh in a fabulous way and of course this
is just a little teaser for what's
coming up
because check out the trailer for what's
coming up
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
and that's international master john
bartholomew with mag
with world champion magnus carlsen who
have given who's who put together this
extremely extensive course the magnus
touch
on the endings we might never be world
champion we might never
uh we might never become magnus carlsen
but we can play with the magnus touch if
we
can study and learn from what he has to
say
we still have some time before before
the second game
lifts off and i think what peter you
and yas were discussing about the london
i think
it's really it's really crazy just how
much trouble this innocent
opening is giving ding and but we did
see him
in the first match win the armageddon
with
uh playing against the london where he
played this slightly offbeat
offbeat setup of going g6 bishop g7 and
that worked out great for him
but of course he knew that magnus would
magnus would prepare against that which
is why he chose a different line and it
just collapsed
really early on and now we're gonna have
ding with the white pieces
what what's your prediction do you think
we
might see a night off we might see an e4
from ding
well thank you for that tanya and i'm
thinking that
uh ding is going to revert to his
classical self
but help us out a little bit because um
peter and i both had the same impression
that
this blitz game the first blitz game
that we just witnessed
was really very favorable for magnus
throughout and the engine sometimes
surprises i'm still shocked that you
told me that [ __ ]
uh said 0-0 in that uh previous ending
was magnus much better or did
the engine feel he was much better i
haven't had the time to look at it right
now
um yes but i will check it out and i
will get back to you but just visually i
think we could all
see just how dominating magnus's
position was and i'm
more interested than the engine actually
i would if magnus does join us at some
point uh
i would really want to know what he
thought about it because i think at the
end of it when you're playing blitz
specially right it's
uh the human way of thinking and the
engines we are thinking are two
extremely different things you have such
little time and we can see the players
are are on there are ready to go for
game two
of the blitz if it's a tie we will have
an armageddon magnus gets to decide the
colors
a big big game for dingler and coming up
i look at these two
and you can just see how um and we've
got liftoff so
take it away yes peter thanks thank you
tanya and
peter we have a repeat
g3 will we see magnus playing c5 no we
won't
no yeah i mean he he changed already
immediately he played second movie six
so no more kings indian structures
enough is enough
magnus put it yeah we see the classical
catalan
yeah i mean of course it's a very very
solid reliable
opening but dingling is really
hell of a big expert so very interesting
to see how this game develops
and in this classical catalan we see
the classical closed catalan variation
with the move uh c7 c6
a lot of players might be surprised why
did the guy go
check and then go back with the bishop
well the idea
is that the bishop on d2 actually
is worse placed on the d2 square it
interferes
with the knight's development and
sometimes even the rook that can come to
d1
so that's the idea behind the bishop b4
check is to lure the bishop to d2
where it might be misplaced now again uh
peter
there was a time that players were
were going 20 uh moves deep and maybe
much deeper
in this catalan and you just mentioned
yourself that uh
dingle loren is a big theoretical
specialist here does that give him an
edge
yeah he's a big expert but this move
order with b6 bishop b7 is
is very rare and okay now finally
ding has reacted with c takes d5 c takes
d5 lux c1
and i just wanted to mention the first
game because i mean
my and i believe also your impression
was that the both players were blitzing
their game and finally it turned out
that malnuts run out of time
where did he take you this time yeah
and now also this brings me to to this
dingly dance
hesitation of like 30 seconds that just
somehow this balancing your open and at
the beginning
might uh play a very big role in the
blitz game um
and now we just see uh the move rook on
f1 to c1 peter
as uh dingler and is eyeballing
an opportunity of perhaps playing queen
to c7
and he's got this knight on e5 that is a
really gorgeous looking piece
and i see that you've just played the
move knight on f6 to d7
before i could extol the virtues of this
beautiful
night you you you kicked me out yeah not
only i kicked you but magnus kid
as well more importantly yeah okay
very nice very nice and dingler and went
back
uh if you know please do share are we
still
in what we would call theoretical
territory or not
no i to be honest i don't think so the
the point is that this b6 bishop b7
if i recall it it used to be uh gabria
sagisians and levon alunyan specialty
back
all the way like 2007. i believe back
then i even
prepared it for one of the games against
levon and i played against him in
modelia if i'm not mistaken but
ever since it it went out of fashion
i can't really recall any new top class
games but
what we are finally getting i believe
that black got
a very reasonable very natural type of
position
everything is harmonious you always want
to develop your knight to c6 because it
gives you this chance of going knight a5
which
magnus also done very nice
knight on a5 i see uh from black's point
of view
black also can play like bishop d6 and
queen e7
uh nice little moves that improve his
position
but he's just dropped his knight on that
great outpost c4
and well i mean uh sorry but to my eyes
you know it almost looks like a fish a
random position p
pieces are getting posted on the first
rank uh
not my favorite rank for my pieces peter
you know what strikes me again that if
we had the clock slide and so far we
always got the clocks right
then again look at this magnus is almost
one and a half
minutes behind on the clock this is not
something i'm i'm used to from magnus
yeah because he's so fast
maybe on the other hand he thinks that
okay give me a good position and i will
handle the clock later
so he takes his time little bit uh at
the beginning
but uh this is something of a new
element in this match
yeah we're nobody's used to magnus being
behind the clock because we've
referenced it so often uh you know he's
beastly uh in blitz and bullet uh
winning the bliss world championship
numerous times
knight b a4 a5 knight b5 beater
inviting a trade of knights on the b5
square
is that a good idea for black or not
well maybe guess what
oh pardon me it hasn't been played is it
a good idea yeah
i i just since you mentioned it yeah i
wanted to state that yeah this pawn on
b5 can be really annoying for black
i don't think that magnus will let this
happen
okay on the other hand the knight on b5
is uh disturbing the question is
will you uh play something like look
take c1 look take c1 queen b8 and then
try to get look c18 or will you try to
play bishop a6
but then there are all kinds of knight
a7 ideas so
magnus is burning time and i'm not
liking this if he goes down
below two minutes true uh
two minutes okay we did see
the former suggestion you made which was
a trade of rooks and queen b8
that looked like the let's say
professional
just you know prepare to the chopping
block
for lots of trades down the c file peter
yeah it was the professional way of
handling things and if you
get one more move look see it then okay
the position will be very very drawish
the question is can
white somehow spice things up with with
b4 but it gives the c4 square
and also entering with the rook to c7
might not lead anywhere because your
rook will look is feeling a little bit
loose on on c7
if you could show that variation say
rook c7 rook d8
i think is the is the problem because
now the rook feels like you say
a little insecure yeah and ding went for
b4
okay as you say i mean if you got to
spice it up right
yeah and e4
c4 b takes a five b takes a5 and e4
played wow
okay things this is spicy
definitely oh that's some samba sauce
uh knight i was about to say
if you play e4 and you
you don't get something material
going uh this could easily rebound
because don't forget that bishop on e1
is really i mean it's not good it's just
not good
and after knight b6 trades
whites traded off his g2 bishop which
was guarding his king
i don't know but it just kind of feels
like
black is having sick more success
uh than white so far with with the
pieces just
my need your uh reaction yours peter
i don't know it's it's so complex and i
understand why ding is taking his time
because uh okay he was the one who
entered this
complications with b4 yeah if you wanted
safety and it's not an armageddon game
it's not like he had to win this game at
all cost
so he played the ambitious move then
magnus immediately reacted with knight
c4 jumped on this
possibility of creating counterplay now
the big question is
whose pawn is weaker the white pawn on
a4 or the pawn on a5
because after all this bishop on e1 is
really not doing that much as you
mentioned but
it uh it targets the the a5 pawn
so everything comes down to the next few
moves we've seen a trade on d5 and
catches up to the current game position
uh
peter ah okay for some reason
it was not updating yeah yeah exactly
because it just the the position
blowed up
yes so we see a very forced sequence
yeah 95 queen piece and bishop takes a5
wow exactly that was the wow i was
thinking about
because knight takes a5 allows rook c7
which is why magnus played bishop to g5
yeah but bishop g5 this is
bishop takes b6 bishop takes
c1 has been played on the board and
bishop c5
what a game holy
whoa and magnus gave up his bishop
with the move rook a a peter
yeah this is this is a already something
i mean an indication that something went
wrong yeah for magnus he
he miscalculated he missed maybe maybe
not miscar created he just blundered
this bishop takes a5 idea
right you know i'm just feeling guilty
because maybe i pushed the wrong button
i wanted to put on
how to update and by clicking wrongly i
uh that was the reason why we didn't go
that update and it was quite an
important moment
and now dingley then is strategically
winning basically this position
yeah materially as well i mean the two
minor pieces versus the rook uh
is one thing but in this position on top
of everything else
white has a great blockading knight and
his own passer
that d-pawn is you know you you put the
bishop on a square
uh-oh but hang on for queen e8
queen a8 that's a turn-around move
oh my goodness queen a8 rook a1
queen h1 mate peter
ding blundered terribly
yeah this is shocking i mean he must
have felt like okay now it's a tactical
opposition
let me make a couple of nice moves
looking back maybe
opening up this long diagonal which
looked innocent
was maybe practically a dangerous choice
i'm trying to look at the players uh i
look i mean it's strange i like it like
ding
always looks like the most worried and
magnus always has this california cool
i thought with the two minor pieces
magnus was in deep trouble and this move
queen a8
i'm sorry it just turns the tables i
just don't see it
i don't see a way a move for ding
anymore rook
a1 is simply a killing blow
yeah this is so dramatic i mean if ding
really
loses this position and ends the
tournament i mean x is the tournament
this is heartbreaking
because looks like he has everything
under control but i'm sorry i
i mean really i i think i think the long
hours that we've all been putting
in uh i just don't see a move uh he's
played
uh queen b2 but there's a rook jack
and there's c3 i suspect there might be
other winning moves as well but
yeah he has played c3 and
now you're in this terrible pin uh
there should be okay there's a back rank
mate
maybe i should just go h6 and queen e4
peter
yeah h6 makes a lot of sense
but also you have the option of playing
something like c2 queen takes c2
and then queen b7 but okay there are
still tricks with
moving the bishop like to b4 so yeah
let's let's just open some
window yeah h6 played yeah luft
as we say we use the german word
luft for air we give a little air to the
king so the king
now has this h7 square that it can
comfortably move to no back rank mates
and white played the move d5 it had to
be played both players done
magnus done to 16 seconds ding 32
it cannot get more dramatic exactly
and now we're expecting queen c8 so that
you hit the bishop and you threaten
queen
f5 as well as ideas of c2 and
that is
a killer move um peter
yeah i mean okay maybe i have to take on
c3 but
yeah this is this is lost yeah because
after takes on c3
takes on b1 with a check king will have
to move and then after rook b5
it will be rook versus bishop three
versus three
easy win and ding therefore decided to
give up his bishop
practically i think that was a wise
decision uh how about you peter
yeah let's not let's not forget both
players have nine seconds each or even
less
this is already not about chess i mean
white got h5 in this is
some kind of a practical chance a big
practical chance
i'm really stunned that uh magnus has
given
because the knight on f4 is suddenly
kind of anchored the problem is is that
maybe
white's king is a little bit vulnerable
peter
yeah now especially after this rugby
queen e4 check
things should have never allowed this
queen e4 i believe
okay looks like that a mate
is about to occur f5
again rook h1 that looks like curtains
at last what a dramatic
game and what a tipsy turvy day we had
today in this
uh semi-final it really looks like
magnus is about to book his seat
into the finals and uh i can see from
ding lehren on my camera
he's just kind of shaking his head what
opportunities he's had peter
exactly and now he's out and magnus in
the final
it could have been a completely
different day
of course very important for magnus not
only reaching the final but also
giving himself an addition extra one res
day because let's not forget magnus had
been playing
the legends tournament all the way to
the final winning the final
so by now he must be really really
exhausted
so one day of uh rest is is what he
needs for before the finals
absolutely i'm sure hikaru wherever
hikaru is he was rooting for ding loren
to go
into overtime but there we have it our
finals are
booked and uh please to everyone get
your questions ready for tanya
she is i'm sure about to interview
uh the world champion as he joins us and
as we wait for
there to join us uh go back through that
sequence if you don't mind peter
that was so uh it just kind of
tactically it all blew up all at once
too
yeah it felt like this whole dynamic
that my auto
auto update uh stopped working had an
effect on the players because
uh in just fraction of a second so many
things escalated here
i believe that this knight e5 move was
was a brilliant move by
biden and he must have forced in it and
relied on it when he
pushed b4 and e4 and uh maybe he
he says the initiative here and magnus i
believe blundered with queen bison
bishop takes c5 but
we have tanya here and i trust tanya
please
we all trust tanya after everything that
we've seen
and how i am completely shaken up with
the chests that we've just
witnessed i don't trust myself guys
it's been so topsy-turvy and i'm i'm
we're still waiting hopefully we'll have
the world champion to take us through
the thoughts but what a match
and this last these two blitz games
absolutely
insane i think the first one um yes you
were asking about did magnus have any
real chances
in that ending i think his best chance i
had a brief look at everything
no clear-cut way but the best chance was
to try and not
trade off that last truck but what uh
instead of uh
on e7 instead he had some other moves
and yeah if you can just back
up a little bit
so around here after knight a5
king f6 here magnus had a nice idea with
knight b5
it's just one of the possible moves and
it's interesting because now you can't
take on e5 just to show that line it
runs into knight c7 knight c6
check and if instead of this you move
the rook
the difference is that if you play
rookie 7 after knight b5
then white just moves away rook d5 now
and we do have i think we can we are
being joined by magnus let me just check
if he's here yes he is um
magnus congratulations
thank you that was a very dramatic day
um you've qualified to the finals but
you look
pretty shaken up right now uh tell us
about how the
your impressions of today's match
because we were we were in shock most of
the
most part for the most part yeah um
i think it was quite similar to
the final match i had against gary in
the in
in the chesapeal masters and that first
game was good and after that it was
was a total mess uh
i i mean i can't believe that i actually
escaped
but uh yeah that's um
that's the way it is sometimes
you did have a great start today uh
winning the first game
but then everything kind of things went
wrong right after game two was
brilliantly played
let's first let's first take a look at
the first game the opening was a
complete
mess but ding was blitzing out his moves
anyway what
what was your feeling around this time
around this moment
yeah so the whole b4 thing is
uh line does not have a great reputation
so i cannot say that i knew too much
about it but i
i was pretty happy with the position um
that i got i felt that i would have
excellent compensation
and of course um the fact that it was
thinking
for a long time after queen a3 was
pretty uncur
encouraging as well um but
but yeah i mean he he gave he gave away
both his
his extra pawns um but
still he was considerably worse and i
was told that he could have made a draw
at some point but
realistically he was always um
in in a lot of peril after this yes
yeah and from now on you made it look
pretty smooth for this game and then
game two happened and before we get to
the second game
uh a lot of people were saying that how
come magnus was playing till the very
end till checkmate and we were just
talking about how sometimes the attack
is so beautiful that
that you guys at the very top let it
play out uh is that
is that the reason why many times we see
checkmates on the board
i mean it could be in this case i just
thought
he was going to play rook f1 and win and
i was going to resign then
and it turned out he had making one so i
think usually
well at least sometimes when people play
it till mate in one it's because they
don't see it certainly that was the case
today
all right fair enough magnus and um but
this was
i mean ding played this game really well
what were what's in this game where do
you think it went really wrong for you
um i think i sort of messed it up a bit
a bit early but
my main issue was that i'd missed bishop
takes h6 when he done he
he did that like i thought the position
was unbelievably dangerous for me in
general
but that i could sort of um
that i could serve escape and then
bishop h6 was just
missed and i missed pitch patch 7 as
well but
uh in general of course he did it
brilliantly
okay fair enough and also going into
game three game four it looked like you
were
on the back foot in both these games uh
were you worried at any point uh
specifically in game three it looked
like the ending had a lot of chances for
black but we weren't
really sure where exactly did you how
were you evaluating the ending did you
believe that you could hold it or
um what was your evaluation of it i
thought maybe it was holdable maybe it
was lost
but i would again
such considerations are not very
interesting when you're when you're at
the board you just
you just try and and find a way to
to play whether it's playing through
when or or for
a draw of course it was very dangerous
but
um at the moment when i played g3
uh when was like
yeah this king d2 was i think quite
important in g3
here i felt fairly safe
um because yeah such endings with uh
pawns on both sides and and and the
bishop when the bishop has
has targets like an a4 they're they're
usually they're usually drown
so this i did not feel so so bad about
but um certainly was was dangerous
and you mentioned a4 we actually were
discussing this if you could just
back up this position do you
did you think about king c4 here as an
option because we felt that would be
perhaps more challenging for white
instead of giving a target on a4 yeah i
thought i thought
this was possible but i go king d2 and
then after king
king goes i go with the king to c1 right
and like d3 king b1 takes yeah
takes and then i give a check and i take
an f7
um yeah
uh i would say maybe just g4
knight e3 and then bishop e6
i don't know if i'm quite in time but
again my impression is that such endings
are usually drawn
your your impressions and your instincts
are absolutely right on that and
even though we felt like this would be
difficult but it actually is
um is absolutely holdable for white
even the interesting thing about these
positions like
is that usually they're either either
winning or
they're just dead wrong and i think
such positions like it looks like marcus
on everything
right he has a um he has an extra pawn
and
and all the pawn my pawns are on
or my one pawn are is on the wrong
square and his
on the right but fixed on the right
square but the yeah
again the problem is it's very hard to
make make progress like you cannot
actually queen
upon against the bishop and knight and
the bishop
this unbelievable shrine yeah it's
exactly like one of those positions
which the
which the computer gives us advantage
but the advantage never really goes up
it's always at that
yeah yeah and uh magnus even in game
four
it felt that uh
that ding was doing quite well from the
start
tell me something during the rapid
portion did you feel
a bit shaky especially after game two
because it felt like ding was constantly
getting better positions in the one
pushing
did you have that feeling oh yeah
absolutely i was
was very shaky and yeah
in this game uh
i would i consider my position to be
pretty much lost here after
after the opening like i i really didn't
play well at all and he
he was just he was just crushing me but
yeah somehow i was fighting back and i
managed to hold
but i don't really know how
and then we went into the blitz and now
in the first game i think um
you after the way the rapid had gone you
had reasons to feel good about your play
in the first game of
um of the blitz portion no
i mean i was unhappy that i couldn't
make any more of
my position than i actually did but
um i don't know i as i said it was it
was just a mess
uh and even yeah even this game
i wasn't that that thrilled about
and then the second one where you
finally managed to win
it was i mean it looked really bad and
then queen b7
was a complete oversight what happened
at that moment when you played queen b7
did you just completely miss bishop a5
or what did you miss
yeah fair enough
and then h4 that was quite quite a gift
uh yeah yeah i mean it's it's it's a
very natural move
uh yes but one that loses
i guess um from what should be a very
good position but
i i would say that even though white is
a lot better
in in the blitz game it's very
very little time it's it's not obvious i
mean i i
still had serious hopes of holding this
but
of course winning it is a bit much
right and then uh where you won it and
magnus you are in the final tell us
immediately after finishing such a
dramatic match what's the first uh
what's the first thought is it relief
yeah obviously
relief um and um
yeah he put up an unbelievable fight
today um
i mean yeah i just needed needed every
inch to
to win this um particular match and
the main takeaway is i just got to be
just got to be better
in in the final
but sorry there's a there's a free day
coming up
and plenty of
plenty of chances to to start again with
um from from scratch it's also been a
very long tournament itself and the
format's pretty brutal and today it
especially felt like
energy and stamina was coming into play
um
you must be happy that you've got one
extra day before finals looks like
you'll be needing it
yeah and what are your thoughts on
meeting
hikaru in the finals from our
perspective it looks like the two most
deserving players have made it
into the finals yeah certainly uh he's
been very very strong in
in the entire tour so it's
it's no coincidence that he's in the
final and
i absolutely agree that uh he he
deserves it based on the way that he
is um he's played
all right magnus um i i'm gonna hand it
over congratulations
uh i know you're very very tired and uh
well done we look forward to seeing you
back for the finals and get some rest
yeah thank you
thank you so much wow
sorry yes okay i just gonna say
congratulations magnus you do look tired
uh
well well done it just seems to me like
just at the very end you just pull
things
out of the fire and you did it again so
well done and maybe peter has a chess
question or two
uh but i'm looking forward to a great
finals
thank you yeah congratulations magnus
to be honest i also haven't seen you so
exhausted as
as you are now so i i don't even know if
it's the right moment to ask any chess
question
so i fully agree if if let's just skip
this
and i would hand it back to tanya if she
has some
more relaxing questions because okay
this match was so
intense and i'm very happy that now that
you did the final you really have this
extra day because
i was talking in the commentary that
having played that legends tournament
and the final and beating yanya
pumnachin the final
in order to get bingley then into the
tournament also i mean you have done so
much for this whole tour
you deserve this res day make the best
out of it and we will be looking forward
to the spring final against hikaru
thanks a all right congratulations
magnus and we'll see you back in the
finals we are looking
forward to an epic fight there thank you
for joining us
all right and there we have it magnus
constant world champion magnus carlson
and hikaru nakamura
five times u.s champion world number one
blitz player just the two most deserving
players have made it into the finals of
the magnus carlsen chester benefiting
kiva finals
i i really don't think we could have set
ourselves up for a more
exciting and a dramatic finish today was
today was just i mean i was thinking
that magnus was going to have it easy
especially the way the last two sets
have gone for tingler and but what an
epic fight ding put up and
congratulations
to dengler and for uh for the way he's
played in the entire tour
and for always coming back and fighting
we've seen him struggle with his
internet connection in previous events
but still he's made it to three
semi-finals in the past in the entire
tour
he's the world number three a
world-class player one of the
one of the most challenging uh opponents
to magnus carlson and we could see today
in the match
why that's the case and also uh
also ding has said that he will be
donating
five percent of his prize money to the
kiva campaign so extreme generosity
thank you so much
ding for your uh for not only providing
us with
all the amazing chess entertainment and
your fighting chess
and just everything that you produce
over the board but also contributing to
the community
uh through chess and also would like to
thank
alan from the us for his contribution
uh who's made a significant donation to
the casper of chess foundation in africa
and uh thank you so much for that we
will be
we will be getting uh more of what's the
conversation on twitter in a bit but
before that
let's get yas and peter because what a
semi-final that
was and i have to say kudos to dinglaren
to come back from a very
difficult loss in game one i mean just
completely got destroyed there but then
how he bounced back and gave such a
difficult fight it was
really anybody's match today no question
about it tanya real roller coaster ride
and quite frankly
i'm a little shocked that we're
interviewing magnus carlson and not
dingler in
because as soon as those tactics at the
end
of the second blitz game
were revealed white had a materially
winning position and ding lorraine is
such a
technically gifted player peter i mean
he's so good
uh in superior positions i really
expected him to kind of win it smoothly
we saw this move h4 and then suddenly we
were both
oh my god i mean queen a8 and it's game
over so
really a topsy-turvy roller coaster ride
and i expected we were going to be
interviewing dingler and peter
there was a moment when i also thought
like this but you know
it was very interesting the moment that
knight c3 rook a5 happened
i somehow had this feeling that i don't
see exactly
white's best move of course i have still
not spotted queen eight
okay one but it really irritated me that
the
move which would basically win the game
is d4 d5
can't be played because the bishop on c5
is hanging yeah
and unless until you can't play d4 d5 in
the blitz game with 30 40 seconds on the
clock
really anything can happen in this this
position of course
h4 queen eight was an incredible shokai
i just don't know how poor
ding felt during the game and how it
feels now because
i think this is such a shock that he
will need quite some time to recover
from
exactly and instead of the move knight
c3 i
i'm i i actually want to end the
broadcast so i could go
check my engine myself and see what he
should have should he played knight a3
was there uh something of that nature
peter there had to be a clean win
because you're right after knight c3
rook a5 you know your natural
inclination is to go d5 and you can't do
it so
it's something irritating about the
position to be sure but
again tanya i gotta say this a
a big shout out to dingler and he is
simply a fantastic player and he
he brings he pours himself
into the game and he gave us a great
show today
yes you're on the money with your
suggestion of knight 83 that was the
right way to play because after that
even if uh
magnus comes in with the queen to b3
you've got moves like queen g5
activating your own
your own queen and as we saw this i
think the thing with h4 as magnus
himself pointed out
it's um uh it's such a
natural looking move and to spot queen
a8 a retreating move because queen a6 of
course does not have the same ideas
because you need to control the long
diagonal as well
it's not an easy move to spot when
you're playing on seconds and you know
it's h4 is the kind of hand move that
you make and
as magnus pointed out it's a natural
move but one that loses on the spot
but in fact if you just move on a little
bit uh
with what happened here after he went
queen v2 okay one
knight b1 and all this was played and
actually at this
and let's go on to d5 and here
queen c8 was the move that actually
gives away some advantage and in the end
ding had managed to stabilize here that
was a really pretty move and i quickly
wanted to show it
uh pointed out by the computers the move
queen to e8
and it's of course a move that perhaps
in a classical game all these
all these players are going to find but
the whole point is that you're
threatening queen e1
if you go if you go something like queen
queen d1 you still have c2 the point is
that c2 pawn will always always take
away
uh the ideas and perhaps even stronger
is to go queen e4 first instead of c2 in
that particular position
because this so the queen on eight
threatens not only queenie one but also
queen eight and this would this gives a
huge advantage and ends the game
queen c8 gave opportunities for white to
come back in the game and ding just
about managed to do it but in the end
messed up and if we just go on a little
more and i want to show you where ding
could have stabilized
he played brilliantly uh after d5 h5
peter as you pointed out h5 was an
extremely important move and let's go on
when he went queen b6 rook b8 and here
ding had to play queen e3 he just messed
up with queen c5 and now these series of
checks that happened on queen e4 and it
was game over with queen e3
and this end game would have been
absolutely holdable for white it's very
difficult for black to break anything if
black keeps the queens on the board
just everything's under control with h5
d5 and this would have been a big
opportunity
but uh what what a round we had just so
many ups and downs and it feels a bit
uh like ding really had some chances
today
in the rapid portion especially and it
was yes just unfortunate but the world
champion
is extremely extremely strong you just
can't give him even a little bit of
um a little bit of anything really
because he just takes it and he just
crushes you and as we see he's
in the finals off the tour
he's won he's won three out of the four
events that he's played
he's in the final but i have to say that
it's a dream final
having hikaru play against magnus we
could not have asked for more
absolutely i just have to get in one
final comment uh for today's broadcast
because i think it was hilarious
in a chess sense we definitely saw it
all right
uh but also i have to say
it cracked me up when magnus said
uh he didn't play to mate as a kind
of a courtesy to his opponent to
recognize and respect
uh the brilliant play of his opponent he
simply missed mayton one
he was ready to resign after rook
okay that's the cherry on top
were you showing your respect to your
opponent or for his brilliant play
no i didn't see making one i just
thought okay now we have seeded
all tanya that was just hilariously
funny for me
yes you're totally right and we went on
and on about how you know when there is
this beautiful attack and you let your
player play out you let your opponent
play out till the very end because as a
sign of
acknowledging this attack and he just
said no i didn't i didn't see the mate
that was quite fun and
yes of course another big shout out to
all to the entire chess community who's
been making contributions
uh to the kiva campaign by
helping to raise money for businesses
that have been affected by the pandemic
and another big
shout out to to allen who
has made a significant contribution and
he's
going to be donating premium memberships
to the casper of chess
foundation in africa thank you so much
uh alan for that and chess is
going to be is a great tool for making a
big impact in the community and of
course we had tani today with us which
was an absolute pleasure
a great ambassador for him for our
impact chess
campaign and for how how truly
chess has impacted our lives and
continues to do so and how we can bring
about an
impact in the world through chess
uh another reminder if you've not had
enough of magnus carlsen
worry not because the action never stops
and we've got more for you there is a
free end game lesson on chessable
that you can go check out and learn why
and how is this guy so good at endings
because he lays it out
bare just his entire thought process of
how he approaches endgames and just all
the tools
that are required uh to become
a strong ending player so definitely go
check that out the whole course is out
tomorrow and let's just see if we can
get up
get a couple of tweets up before we wrap
up the show for today tomorrow is of
course a rest day
and uh we will all besides
besides the players the commentators
will also will also be having a rest so
yes
peter enjoy your rest and uh let's say
goodbye to our audience and we'll see
you
there after for an epic epic final
likewise tanya peter it's always a
pleasure to work with you both
thank you every one of you for joining
us
and we will see you for the finals so
good night
yeah thank you yasir thank you tanya bye
bye
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
you